Okay, who's doing what?
Roma, you get out of the kitchen and you just cream that.
I'm gonna look for like spare rope like.
Okay, you should be able to find some rope in like your surprise that the explorers
bag that you started with, it should have like 50 feet of hemp and rope already.
So you should be able to get it from your bag.
My amelphis.
I'm gonna see Roma like, tying the rope around his waist like.
Yeah, yeah.
Are you gonna talk to Serka?
Yeah, go ahead.
Both of them are on the mast.
The crow's nest, sorry, as usual.
The sitting, laying down.
So you fly up there at the crow's nest, what are you saying?
So hope you're not too angry about just to do.
Sorry, I couldn't you.
She looks at you, she's kind of just because like when easy on you don't think you're gonna
get away with it next time, okay?
Oh, so I don't care about these stupid rankings anyway.
She just looks away.
William just looks at you and just smiles if you're, you know, just drugs.
Hey, that's where's my victim?
Are you saying sorry?
You know what, just let them run away all the time.
Well, you're good at that.
So you should be able to catch him.
That's fine.
William is probably still hearing all of this.
I tried to go easy on Bob, but don't think I'll go easy on you.
You're almost as fast as me now.
I don't plan to leave it at floating.
All right.
Well, as long as you don't piss me off, I think we should be fine.
I'll just jump both.
Okay.
Romero, what are we saying?
Hey, Baptiste, where's my victim?
Has anyone seen Bob this morning?
I was the bomb at all.
I'll just cool up.
Yeah, we can well, looks down at you guys as he says.
You want me to look for Bob?
I can make you maybe do around and look for him.
Yes, please.
Both in the covered grinning like they're never going to find me.
Bob, just disappear as like a little streak just runs around the whole place as Bob,
you hear like a knock at the cabinet here inside.
He freezes.
Doesn't even breathe.
Bob, I know you're there.
I looked around everywhere.
Just get out.
We get well, I can't do that.
So, you know, unless I want to die.
What are you so worried about?
You almost took me out yesterday.
Should be able to take a run.
I'm not supposed to be fighting, you know, that's not my job.
And also, have you seen that guy?
You have already given me a pretty big headache, okay?
Okay, Bob.
Let me get real with you for a second.
We used to have someone who didn't really like to fight.
Two, so I understand where you're coming from.
But the way things are going, I don't think you can go forward without fighting.
I heard that the old man is already missing.
And whatever you're looking for, they're not just going to come strolling in.
You have to go pick fights.
And there's no better way to fight with people you trust.
Get a hang of it.
Or maybe I could, you know, focus on my communication skills.
Bob get out.
Uh, he has a plan.
Uh, yeah, Bob has a plan.
So he says, well, let's go.
Let's talk with Roma.
Okay, that's fine.
Uh, we'll just face palms and those.
I think that's the last person you should have it talking to, but all right.
Bob, you come out.
They're supposed to fight and wait there.
Right.
So, uh, a few seconds pass a few minutes.
And everyone is now stopped.
And these guys, as usual, are taking their position up on the closeness to watch the fight.
Let me move to the other school.
All right.
Now, please take it over.
You are now in the second day of this.
Right.
Turn it.
And to decide the last and say them to last place.
Bob will be fighting.
Are you both ready?
Oh, wait.
Two things. Wait.
Uh, first of all, is it a new day? Did we take a long rest?
Yes. Yeah. You can take a long rest. Yeah.
Oh, it's a new day. Yeah.
You're probably going to do this.
And you can also do your cute thingy, your box.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, let me do the major armor.
There you go.
Oh, it's 19 and 10. I mean, 19 was good. 10. Maybe not so good. But all right.
Yeah. How much should I have to succeed on the cute thingy?
What thingy?
15 plus.
Yeah. You need to roll.
Roll for the cube again to solve it once more.
I need 15 plus total, right?
Yeah, intelligence. Just plain intelligence.
Right. Oh, plain intelligence. I can't get that with 10.
Yeah. I'm going to use my no, never mind.
I mean, you could just roll and they can.
Try try to roll if it works. It works.
So you're. Yeah, you're two percent closer now instead of one percent.
So just increase it to instead of six, it should be.
Eight. Yes. If you can edit it, if you can't edit it, let me know.
I actually did it for you. Leave it.
Okay. I'll see you in the next video.
I think it was a box 8%. Right.
So I'd say in the morning, you are in the evening yesterday after the fight.
You'd be working on that plus on your other thing.
I almost step in the ring.
All right. So I'm in the ring. I remember I.
I tied myself up to the mess.
You should be you should be able to move around.
You said there was 50 feet, right?
So I was 50 feet. Yeah.
10 feet around yourself.
Yeah, you should be able to move around like a 40, 50 meter area like in this area.
Yep. That's the me. Let me actually place the thing. So we remember.
So yeah, let's say that's much. This is the area you can move around in.
Oh, wait. You're talking to yourself and with the math.
Okay. That's a problem.
Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, shit. Here goes the only plan I had.
No, no, no, no, that's not the plan.
I was planning with to win this with communication.
Yes. Yes.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's the.
And then.
It's going to look at Roma and like prep himself up for a like.
Like, you know, the one looked at businessmen's give like the negative.
Negotiation.
Uh,
look, I'm not exactly a fighter, right? So, um, I don't have the whole.
Fighters pride or ego thing. So, uh, winning or losing a fight isn't.
Or like fighting for honor. That's not really, uh, something that I deal with.
So even if I lose this fight, it's not.
It's nothing for me. So, uh, do you want to fight me?
I want to see what you got.
You're.
I was okay. So you want to ask me, right?
I'm not.
Like, okay. So here's my, uh, offer.
You know, the only reason I joined the tournament was because Vail said I should learn more about the people's power and all.
And when the previous fight I learned, I got a chance to use Vail in my experience.
Vail, I'm holding you to your word.
You got it, big man.
You have a devil fruit as well in you.
So, here's my proposal.
Uh, we do this fight. You're going to have to like, uh, help me with my experiments on devil fruit.
So, yeah, I'm not going to, uh, like, uh, can your shit or something and like cutting your belly is still out of the, probably out of the, uh, thoughts.
So there are other experiments.
So if you, uh, agree to be my genie pig.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I will agree to fight.
Otherwise, I will forfeit a match.
Time out, time out, you said other experiments like what are you trying to give me a prostate exam? Like what are you trying to build?
No, no, there are a lot of experiments you can do.
Like, uh, physical exam, like your mental exam, how I mean, I can get your mind and see what I, what changes when you like transform, like get you reading, you know, I was in
an interrogator in black and screw. So I can read your thoughts. So there's a lot of experiments. If you're a interrogator, why are you being such a scared to catch?
Because I was not the good cop or the bad cop. I was the cop behind the, uh, behind the guy that they were investigating and I was to read their thoughts when the other guys were interrogating them.
That's what we got. That's what we got a science and pussy. Come on now. What are we going to do with this?
Yeah, here's my, here's my proposal though. You'll be my genie pig. I'll fight you. Otherwise, I'm for it for fitting. Do you want to fight me?
Let's fight me dad.
Alright, let's, let's leave it to fate.
Okay.
Wait, you, you, you've been fired me? Yeah, I'm still going to, I want to fight you. I want to see what you made up.
That's my, that's where you're very, very, now that's fair. Man, think of what the experiment.
Well, we don't, we don't flip a coin. Head your tails.
Okay, that's, that's too little chance. After 50% is not good for me.
I'm just fine.
It's either, it's either I do your experiments or I accept your tap out. Like it's 50, 50.
Oh, forget it.
Yeah, you don't want to, you don't want to roll the chance?
No, I know my luck. Never mind. I know what's going to happen.
Yeah, we see what you're about. And if you put up a girl fight, then I do what you ask.
I'll shit in the bucket for you.
Really?
Yeah, I'm not going to lose this.
Okay, no shedding. Okay, that, that's out of the question.
But what?
I'll be your guinea pig, but I'll be your wolf.
That's if you put up a fair fight.
You did this runaway position, you know.
I might have to, I might have to smash.
Oh,
I mean, that's more important.
Yeah, I'm done.
Cyborg becomes my new, my new microwave, you know what I'm saying?
Derek is going to lose her man.
So we have a deal.
I guess you're going to put up a fair fight.
Defend zone with the definition of a fair fight.
You're going to win like a pussy or you're going to stand here.
You're going to we're going to do this thing.
Well, runaway is one thing. You know, that ain't a fight.
I didn't say I won't run away.
You said you would put up a fight.
I'm going to run my real furnished out.
Okay,
I won't go first.
Oh, well, right.
Go Bob.
Well, it says that.
I just want to know if we doing this.
You ain't going to be running away.
You ain't going to be doing the little hazaa.
Shoot me up in the air.
We are a fight.
I want to see that warrior spirit come out.
I want to hear that warrior call.
Can you guess here?
Oh, yeah, you could hear.
I can stop that now.
I'm waiting for the bell.
The ding ding from Baptiste.
Alright.
Baptiste call it.
Who goes first?
Bob.
You go, you go first.
Oh, shit.
Who knew this could happen?
I don't know what you're doing.
Oh, I'm still waiting on the ding ding.
We doing this bucket.
You know what I'm doing?
I'm walking up.
I'm popping that rage.
We fucking.
He got me pissed off.
Make me wait.
Well, goodbye, Bob.
Hey, go.
And I'll even do it recklessly.
Come on.
Give Bob a chance.
Is that so is that with that delay?
Do it.
Never mind.
We know what's going to happen back on your turn.
You can decide to.
Oh, give it.
It's finished it quickly.
And those don't hit.
13 does not hit.
Yep.
It's your turn, Bob.
Bob.
Okay, here's my question.
Over here.
This is a mask, right?
Yes.
Which.
Uh huh.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, below this is also a pillar.
Is there space behind the mask over here?
Yeah.
You have enough to sing.
You can move here.
Yep.
Let me move that.
Okay, there you go.
I will move that.
Okay.
You're in five feet.
You're going to take.
Opportunity.
Yeah, true.
Uh, no, I'm just engaging and running down.
Okay.
You want to come here.
You got to.
Yeah.
You have enough to sing.
You can move here.
Yep.
Yeah.
Okay.
Do you want to do something else, Bob?
I'm going to come here and I'm going to reach inside my back and pull out my little fucking throw an axis that I got.
Nice.
Oh.
How many do you have?
What's that?
I have two.
Okay.
I just get a survive, too.
All right.
I got two.
I also have four javelins.
Oh, fuck.
All right.
Check one.
How do you throw like?
You just click.
Click on the hand.
X.
Okay.
Hand.
And then attack.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
23.
We're going to do the damage.
I believe Bob.
That's my friend.
Yeah.
This one just for eyes, actually, Bob, with just piercing for lost.
I don't know.
I'm just going to take a look at the screen.
I just got a look at the screen.
And then I'm just going to take a look at the screen.
Okay.
Concentration.
What happened to no killing?
Do the concentration at all.
What concentration?
I'm not concentrating.
It's saying you're concentrating on something.
Let me check what you're concentrating on.
Okay.
All right.
You have extra attack if you want to use Roma.
Otherwise, you can end your turn.
Oh, I thought pulling it out of the pack was.
No, no, no.
It's you should be like, no, it's not an action to pull it up.
Oh, that should have thrown another one.
Fuck.
Oh, wait.
Are you from level five?
No, I don't think so.
He got an extra attack, right?
Yeah, I got frenzy.
Oh, I think that's a frenzy.
Yeah, frenzy.
Yeah, yeah.
So then.
Yeah, do frenzy and then throw another.
Oh, frenzy is only melee.
Oh, it is only melee.
Yeah, yeah, sorry, sorry, sorry.
You can do that.
Yeah, the number one.
Yeah, I thought I could throw one.
Okay.
No, that's his turn.
Bob, what are you doing?
Okay.
So first things first, I get a look out for myself over here.
I'm going to like stand over here and ask.
I'm trying to survive.
All right.
I'm going to pass.
Where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Mirror image on myself.
All right.
All right, that's going to be.
You know what?
Since we're doing this, let's do this.
Yeah.
Let's throw him.
Since I, because he needs.
He needs to be.
It needs to be a fair fight or whatever he thinks.
So for him to help me with my experiments.
So I'm going to attack him.
Okay.
There you go.
Roma.
Wait.
Uh, isn't that an action?
You can't cast mirror image and.
I'm not doing.
I'm not doing anything.
Never mind.
It happens.
Okay.
So good.
Cool.
Uh, Roma, it's your turn.
If I try to throw something through this mass or you're going to be pissed off, Abby.
I'm not going to be pissed off.
Go ahead.
Roll another.
No, no, no.
We have to play by the rules.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'll just do this.
I don't want you to do it.
But I
I'm not going to do it.
God dammit, Paul.
What is it?
I'm doing what I'm best at doing.
I'm running away.
What is my movement speed?
I forget it.
It's a 20 or 25.
It's 30 probably.
Minimum needs to be 30.
Yeah.
Oh, well.
This shit.
I could go right there.
Yeah.
Don't go on top of me.
I'm just going to normal swing twice because the reckless is not working today.
Yeah.
I'm going to do it.
I'm going to pop this and just.
And then you're going to present normal swing.
I know it.
That's a great.
I told you.
Also, Roma.
By the way, before you roll the damage, I'm still through.
Feel your thunder, but you have to roll that again.
You're using portant.
I have no other option.
I need to be alive.
Come on.
Okay.
So you're using the 10 portant.
So 10 does not head bob.
It does not head bob.
So Roma, you basically go up.
You try to slam your skillet into Bob twice, but both time Bob just clicks a button on his arm.
One of the times you feel like you just hit him straight in the head.
But then you're just standing there and Bob is on the side.
The second time you try to hit him, you're just so confused that you don't know.
You just missed the second one.
Next is Bob.
Bob, you saw Roma just hit you straight in the head.
You just got lucky and you clicked the button.
But now you're kind of after the side of him.
What do you want to do?
I have no other way.
I just have to do one thing.
So here goes my only plan of the day.
Where did it go?
Wait, what?
Oh, there it is.
I have a D.C. 14 constitution safe.
So constitution safe.
Just click on the constitution safe and let's see if it succeeds or not.
I'm sorry for this, but you have to roll that again.
I'm casting for very bars on that on top of levitate.
No, very bad.
Yeah, reaction to him hitting you, right?
Is it reaction to everything?
No, it's reaction to succeeding on the safe.
Okay, okay, okay, yeah, when you let me check should take a few issues.
You succeed.
No, no, no.
Never even mine.
Yeah.
You cast it.
I still just fucking.
Okay, well, he succeeds.
So the little bug, kind of creatures just latch on to Roma as they're trying to thrust him
through.
But the weight of Roma is too much.
That's the best.
I'm not going to be able to do that.
What the hell is even happening?
You know what?
As this one, I'm tired.
I'm fucking tired.
Robo at this point with you like bent skillet you just wonk, uh,
Robo at this point with you like bent skillet you just wonk, uh, barb in the head and Bob you fallen conscious for a while.
Bob Fall down falls down like a rock.
Boom.
Well, carry his ass and put him in the spoke.
So that way he's out of the way.
Let me do that for you.
Oh, there we go.
Yeah, there you go.
All right.
At this point, Baptiste would conclude that Rob was the winner
and we'll move on to the next fight.
All right.
What?
Yeah, no shit.
The guy is a loser.
I kind of want to fight you again.
I'll put you in the ground this time.
Yeah, no way.
I almost killed you.
I almost had you twice now.
Twice.
I almost had you.
Well, you know, there's a keyword there almost.
Third time I'm going to get you.
We'll see.
At this point, you see, wail down there is like jumping on his feet
and kind of getting ready for the fight.
As he looks up at your mouth,
and he's going to just sprint in front.
I'm going to gather my rope.
I'm going to gather my rope in my fucking axis.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're just standing on it waiting.
I did the role.
I just got.
Yeah, just waiting.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, as soon as.
Real quick.
Roma crosses.
Oh, shit.
Where is he just going to sprint right as soon as Roma crosses
and he's going to do quick blade.
Oh, shit.
That.
That hits.
It's going to do the damage.
Wait, is he the suppressed one?
It is the suppressed one.
And the fight begins.
There you go.
He just sprints at you as he just cuts one like sliver
from your cheek as like the blood drips down.
And he's going to be right behind you.
What are you going to do, Malfa?
That's his turn.
It's bedtime.
Where time.
Let me go.
Let me see.
Give me one second.
Transformation.
That's the only way I can sort it.
I should have to.
I have a question for you.
Yeah.
Since my like Yeti form gets like snow abilities.
Does his bird like like my normal claws do snow effect?
Does his claws do like lightning?
Yes.
Well, it used to do magic, but then I just changed it to lightning.
Because that made more sense.
Yeah.
And then I get use of the powder.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what I thought.
I just wanted to ask before I didn't interrupt.
I'm sorry.
No, no, no, go ahead.
I'll shut up there.
All right.
Hey, BFT.
I got five.
Well, what you got?
Fuck off.
This battle for a month.
That's Syracal.
No, it's that one hits that one hits.
Hey, Daniel, we're taking bits.
What you want?
I got five on veil.
What you got?
I'm going to put 20,000 bellies on the birdman.
You said 20,000?
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
We doing small bets.
We ain't got money like that.
Well, then I'm not participating.
As you guys are screaming this stuff over the mast, where as soon as it cuts mouthless,
you see mouthless just start to turn as soon as like the blood starts dripping.
He starts to turn into his hybrid form and he turns around, tries to hit one of the
talons, but will the ducks underneath and the other tunnel comes in from underneath
and just like an uppercut, just scratches, will snack.
Well, it's going to go, I expected you to do that.
Well, let's see if you can handle this.
He's going to go to quick blade.
He's going to do an action search.
He's going to quick blade again.
Stop heading so high.
Damage.
There you go.
And you see he pulls out now both blade this times and just tries to just, you know,
you just don't see his hands.
You just see like the outline of the blades just hitting you both times.
I go and there you go.
As he moves over on this tide.
He's just a battle of attrition who goes down first.
20 hits.
Another one.
Oh, that was just damage.
Let me actually make sure I hit first.
20 hits.
19.
Let me do that.
Okay, let me do that.
Okay, how do you, how do you do this?
Just slam into him twice.
You just use your hand like kind of sort of like a blade.
And then he goes.
Well, actually, let's see if he can get this aerial.
What?
Oh, you're going up.
Okay.
God, damn it.
I was afraid you're going to do that.
I mean, I mean, I just get both of them trying to see how far.
Yeah, he's not going to get part of this point, but he is going to take out his like thumbdarts.
And he's just going to throw them.
One, two,
miss.
12 and 12th.
Both the thumbdarts just go straight up as you just sway and dodge those.
And those are going to go straight in the ocean.
And he goes.
All right.
It's going to be his move.
It's your turn.
All right, let's slam down.
And do a thunderbolt.
No way.
Do a DC 10 con save.
No, it should be more than 10 because it keeps reaching to.
I don't know a lot, but it should be wisdom.
Let me check then.
13.
It's 11.
So he probably still fails.
All right.
He's failed to damage.
As like these shrines of lightning just goes to him.
And you see at this point, the lightning kind of devolves around him.
But it still hits him.
Yeah.
Thunder damage or whatever.
We flavored it as lightning, but yeah.
Another difference, but I'm just doing the flavor.
I think he's going to take full damage.
He's not made of lightning.
Yeah, let me first do the damage.
I'm going to move him.
10 feet backwards.
There you go.
So you drop down to this or do you just drop down to current position?
Okay.
Just slam down and do the thunder.
So you slam down the roll and just put your arms in front as like these lightning strands come out and.
Hit him.
He's forcing him back 10 feet as you rolled over on his knees.
He stands up.
He's going to go.
Oh, he's giving me more.
Rubble than I thought you would.
He's going to go.
You know what?
I'm just going to do.
Wicked blade.
You're going to run to you and he's going to do quick blade again.
Oh, you're trying to 10 feet up.
Okay.
Oh, fuck.
Then you can't do quick blade.
I'm going to do it again.
He's going to throw one dart again to you.
And let me do the critical.
So let me lower that by a bit.
Oh, I think it's one attack is four darts.
So that's why it's like that.
Okay.
That's wrong.
You throw.
Okay, 10.
So you take 14 damage.
Let me do that.
Yeah, it's like still two of the darts hit you right there on your wings.
And he's going to do second wind.
Where's it?
There you go.
It's not a lot.
Okay, that's his turn.
Go see his out of the darts, but.
Fuck off.
You slam down with your claw.
You don't hit him.
The first one.
There you go.
It doesn't hit.
Yeah, so of first strike, you just miss the second strike.
You feel like you touched him, but he's like he just.
Sways like an afterimage of him.
You hit that afterimage, but for the second one, you kind of know his movement.
So you just slam right into his face.
Okay, do the damage.
There you go.
Did it not.
Fly.
There you go.
There you fly up again.
I'm getting tired of this.
I don't want to use my blades.
God damn it.
I didn't want to use this, but all right.
He's going to get up to 60 feet.
And then he's going to push you down.
With quick blades.
One more.
24 head.
17 head.
Hello.
I can't hear anyone.
I think it hits.
Let me check 16.
Yeah, yeah, both heads.
I think it's going to be a little bit more.
I took some damage before.
Eight damage.
Yeah, you didn't do long rest.
That's why, okay.
Eight damage is...
Oh, before the fight.
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, I forgot.
24 and then minus eight is...
36 or 16, okay.
And the second one is...
12 again.
So you're left on four, Jesus.
Okay.
So he basically beats you down with both of the blades
right in your chest as you both pummel down on the ground.
All right.
It's your turn.
I just didn't know what to do.
Zero.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Jesus, this is bad.
I just do flurry, bro.
You did a lot of damage, so you can actually win if any of you...
I got the shit.
All right.
Roll one again.
Is that it?
You didn't flurry.
Okay.
Just died.
Yeah, this one hits.
Fucking golf.
Two damage and we go here.
And this one, you slam one of your fists right in his chest
as he is on top of you.
And both of you just lie down toward each other.
And then he's like, "Oh, thanks, his Wales turn."
All right.
I'm to finish this.
But yeah, if he hits, I'm down.
Yeah.
Let me see.
Quick blade.
Attack.
He does not hit.
It's your turn.
No.
He hits.
Right.
This point, both of you are barely standing.
And...
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
Six.
How do you want to do?
Let's go.
Now, this with the comeback.
Yeah.
No.
Around this time, you kind of start to get up and you just see
what is happening.
Wait.
The whole show.
You didn't miss the last few set of few minutes.
Okay.
Now, let's go ahead.
Right.
So as he's laying on top of me, I sort of get my wings free
for underneath and just fly a bit and slam them down with it.
Okay.
As you slam him down, the...
The area of the ship that...
Right this year, you slam him through that and on to the ground
as well as now lying there unconscious.
And psycho rolls up.
Here she goes.
Good job.
I actually didn't think you could do that.
Daniel, there goes.
What?
Well, I need my money, Roma.
I told you, you're a small bit.
You want the five that I put up?
Yeah, I'll take that.
I have to fix this shit.
All right.
Well, and you are right now lying down in the lower deck.
Yeah.
I'm just going to roll off then and lay down next to him for a bit.
Oh, that's East.
You will come up and you will try to see who is standing right now.
Well, it's completely not that as the small clears from below.
You see, mouth is just tired, just heaving.
The winner is mouthless.
You can see all three of the spiders kind of clapping from up top.
Is the Galelia?
I'm going to help.
Helping and helping and school dollars of deck again.
Okay, you fly up and you put well down right beside you.
And he starts to get up because.
Well, wow.
Damn.
You improve real fast.
Holy.
Well, I guess that's that.
Yeah, good fight, man.
I see.
And a doubt.
Well, that said, that's the.
That's the point.
I'm going to go ahead and say,
ahhwyeah i think we are all not going to get your uhh....
we will in circle gonna move to the cross nest as the uhh.....
Should i go to OGisclear?
Tryis czar
Let's see the true power weights
uhh....
Alright what do you guys want to know?
I'm cooking so i don't whatever they want to do i can...
mmhmm
Are you doing the final fight today or....
Uhh....
We can't do anything left
Yeah i mean you guys can spend the day and....
Really?
I think we should have a lot of time
If you guys want to talk or do anything else during this you can do that
Otherwise we could skip to the next day
No i'm just gonna be cooking food throwing it up to people making sure everybody's fed
No i will like your whole set of brother got it his ass beat
I think most got beat like it
Yeah that's what i was saying
I think who's last?
Bob is dead last
Hey who the fuck are you?
Uhh....
So it's bathees, melphus, then Roma
No, then cerca, then Roma, then Bob right?
Oh yeah
There we go
Bathees, melphus, whale, cerca, Roma, Bob
Okay, go go
Not that it matters
No, nothing it matters
Uhh....
It kinda does
Okay
The decision is made if Bob says something is not important
We don't know
I'm gonna go and see Bob and be like hey i need that frosting
Say what?
He's so there's gonna be other tests
What?
I'll be like, I'm gonna be like hey oh Bob
You said there's gonna be other tests like it's up from a prostating exam
Oh fuck now
Okay, so good
My head hurts okay
I'm gonna rest today and like focus on my stuff
And yeah just let's forget the whole shitting
And the prostating ever happened okay
That's never happened
That is not included in the whole experiment thing
But wait
So you still
You still up to be the guinea pig?
No about guinea pig but I'll let you do some weird tests like
I mean if you're talking about prostating exams I'm gonna tell you right now I don't swing that way okay
So
You're assigned whatever you're thinking we're not doing that okay
What do you mean whatever I'm thinking
I mean I'm not gonna do to me
Okay
First you were talking about looking at our poop
Now I just figured you wanted to figure out where it came from
No okay look my head hurts let's talk about this later and
Forget about the whole prostating okay
I don't mention that
Can I look around for a moment
Did you get the do your role I ask
You're pretty far away from fish man islands so
Oh my god
There's a mermaid right here
No that's not gonna be it's gonna be a thing
You're holding it
Yeah yeah you see something you see something lying like on a log
Like kind of like a person
It's a walrus
Yeah
What do you do
What
Read I read to the dog someone's over there
He takes out like the telescope in zooms and he sees
It looks like a person
Alright he turns the wheel
To like around here somewhere
You see like the body now keeps floating in this way
Are we taking this
I like to get through a companion
To inspect when they get closer and try to help them
You can try to pull like a rope and pull them up
So you can just fly down and just grab them
Do decks
Check just normal
Just check just check
You should be able to pull whatever you saw down there
And now that you're like lifting them up
You can see like
It's not a mermaid it's a person
It's a woman around 20
Okay
You're just putting worse in the amount
So you
A lot like a woman
She's in like a bunch of like black
And she's not like breathing right now at this point
Well you put her down
Wait black ape like a pirate
No, no, no, just clothing
Okay, anyone know basic
CPR
Yeah, I'm gonna like
Yeah, I'm gonna open my bag
And my owl flies out
Goes to the person and lands on it
Persons on her face or whatever
And then I click a switch and the owl's talent glow
And then I'm gonna cast cure wounds for
How much let's see please roll a good number for once
Okay
It's not a
Okay, how much is it six
Yeah, that should be able to
Get her up
So you see this owl flying in
And
From the talent of the owl you see kind of like a syringe
Come out and just stab this person in the chest
As she
She's
Pours out like a bunch of water
Throws up a bunch of water as she coughs
And wakes up
And she starts to see
That he's like right above her as the owl flies away
Towards a
Bob as she just jumps back
Scuttles a bit at the edge of the ship here
As she goes
What the hell do you want
Are you okay
She looks at the flag up there on the ship
She goes
What's that?
Are you
No, no, no, no, the spider's nest.
Yeah, it's the spider's flag.
Yeah, that's what I meant.
How did you get out?
Oh, look, I don't know what you want from me, but just let me go.
I have money.
Just let me go.
You can take all of it.
Look around.
Where are you going to go?
Just give me one of those boats.
Just leave me alone.
I know what the words do.
Look, I don't
Who said
I don't know what you're up there.
Look, I don't care about whatever you're
I just want to leave.
I don't want to explain anything to you.
I don't know what you're up there.
She's still like holding.
You either tell us what you're doing out here.
We're throwing you over the fucking ship.
With no boat.
You're asked the highest.
What the fuck are you doing out here?
She looks up.
She goes.
Blade still in her hands.
She's like,
she's like,
she doesn't see you.
As she's
Chloe kind of climb up onto the mask from the other side to the side.
She goes.
This one.
You have five seconds.
Okay, just just.
I'll tell you.
I'm just on my way to my home.
Okay, just I don't want any trouble.
I was on a merchant trip.
It capsized.
I just wanted to make my way back to log town.
Just.
Kind of, but no, just just.
I'll give you the money.
I'm going to see it better again.
I don't want any trouble.
Shut up, shut up.
I don't make you some food.
You just tell Baptiste where this island is.
Okay.
Well, can I just go?
What happens to everyone else on the merchant trip?
I don't know, you know, but I, I've been survived.
I hold held on to that fucking log for as long as I could.
I remember.
I'm going to buy something.
I don't know how I'm still alive, but.
I think so.
I need to get back.
Who are you?
I'm going there.
Because I saved you.
Okay.
My name is them.
I work for pirates sometimes, but you really do not work with pirates.
I mostly do.
God damn it.
I'm going to regret this.
I do with moons.
But I have no legions to them.
Okay.
Just let me go.
We are only and just free to you'd free to whatever, whatever.
If you want something to help regarding anything, just let me know if I have heard anything about it.
I'll, I'll, I'll, I'll be sure you'll be able to help you.
Which way is a home, where is home?
Which way?
In the east, there's a town called Loke Town.
Have you heard of it?
Have I?
Loke Town.
You have heard of it probably.
So one of the islands.
That is what I've heard of it.
Is it on our way to?
Is the town Luffy and the other guy stop at before River Smongton?
Is that Island?
No, no, it's in the east blue.
North.
You're going in, you're in the Grand Line right now.
We can take you there.
You'll just have to.
Right along with us until there.
I just, just give me one of the boats.
I'll sail through the close of silent.
And that's it.
I don't want to be seen with pirates.
Is that so hard to understand?
I don't want to trouble.
And pirates use wind cost trouble.
Well, the last, the closest island gone.
It's blown out.
The land's gone.
You don't want to know.
She momentarily like puts down her blade in her pocket as she takes out her notebook and she writes down.
I don't know what mess you've gotten yourself into.
I don't know why you're on the spiders ship who you are because I.
I can care less.
Just give me the boat and I'll be on my way.
I'm going to go to the bubble to get out of this food.
He looks at the food.
Yeah, she looks at the food and she just goes.
Yeah, no, I'm not taking anything from strangers that I don't know.
I'm just going to leave it here.
You eat it when you're ready.
Okay.
Well, who's the only sponsor here?
You've been speaking to him this whole time.
Okay, okay.
So I think that we're not giving you the road.
I told you what could happen.
You can accompany us and we'll take you back.
She just thinks boats come like they're free.
Yeah, you're going to be using something that you probably want.
Just tell me what you want.
Any info regarding the news, regarding fucking German.
Everything, tell us everything, you know.
I can't really do that.
You know, informants have a job and the job is to show information.
If I tell you everything, then I'm useless.
Well, right now you're useless.
You want one of our boats.
We only got two of them.
Hello.
Is this guy know how to barter?
That's not the way to throw her in the water.
This is the guy that helps the person bartering.
Okay.
He intermedeering.
Intermediate.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, no.
The other one.
Intimidation.
Yes.
Okay.
Anyway.
Can I ask.
Have you, do you know about viris?
As soon as you say that name, her face drops.
Who are you people?
We know about him.
That was wrong with you.
We are his friends, we're supposed to find him.
This time, my guest.
Second, we'll probably hear about this.
Well, we'll jump down and walk through you as he goes.
What's the commotion about?
To me or?
To that piece.
I know.
Very.
Hmm.
I feel like if she wants her somewhere.
She's up to her blade and puts her leg goes it down.
And she just kind of stairs at her.
She just scuttles back and she goes.
You want to.
Again.
Okay.
If you want to know that.
I know I might have a clue.
I have been following them for about two weeks.
That's a man fall.
I was told by the.
I have a little bit to look into him.
And that's that's all I know.
I know where he was at least last week.
Well, it kind of looks down and he goes.
Oh, you you that.
Yeah.
Do you know someone by the name of faster.
Who goes to the girl?
The girl that was.
Yeah, how do you know about him?
I'll just go.
Nothing.
He's just.
An old friend.
He runs back and you go to.
That's the one.
If she knows where it is, it's probably worth.
The dry to get some information out of her.
Bob, you were saying before you used to be the.
No, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't.
Hey, dude.
I don't know.
The moment he even talks about it.
The one you open to mine.
I say, hey, dude, dude, dude, dude.
I'm not sure if he was.
Yes.
Where's you going?
Where's Pipsquee going?
Oh, follow her.
He's just not going to respond to that.
He's just going to respond to that.
Where's Pipsquee going?
Do you have a spell that can bind somebody in place like Freeze?
Do you have rope for that?
Why?
We ain't got rope.
I mean everyone else probably still have rope.
We do got rope, but we ain't got rope.
You know what I'm saying?
I'm saying like you can't do it.
I'm getting it.
Like, I'm being honest here.
Like, she asleep.
You just freeze her.
He could grab it.
We could go.
Well, he can't grab it because of the stone.
Bob came.
Yes, I can.
Well, if you guys want to go that way,
you guys can just overpower her, tie her up, and then take her.
But.
The interrogation.
It might cause problems.
Okay, so guys, we need to come up with a plan.
Are we taking it today?
Because like, if we take it today.
Okay, in that case, I need a spell.
So I am really tired, my head hurts.
So wake me up after one hour and check on her if she is asleep or not.
I need to sleep, guys.
And Bob's going to take a short rest.
How many hours do you want to skip?
Times, skip to night.
Yeah, one.
Okay, so, what's the plan?
Everyone is going to sleep.
That no kind of.
What's the anchor down?
And he goes down in his sleeping quarters.
No, no.
I'm not going to keep watching.
Well, these guys are not going to keep watching.
No, that.
You guys are you guys.
They are separate.
They have no relation to you people.
You can tell where in circuit to do something if you want to.
They're probably going to be in the closeness sleeping.
It's going to be around 10 o'clock, 10 p.m.
Sorry.
Okay, Bob.
No, the win circles are on the top of the mast.
Sorry, the closeness.
And what I guess I want to do.
You're in the kitchen.
Yep, yep.
He's passed out resting.
Was there a window in the bottom that she could see like the sky from?
There should be like small several windows.
I would like to.
No, no, first, what you doing?
I need to talk to Roma about something.
I don't know.
I like the.
Base.
What's the story body?
And blend in with this guy so I can peek into her.
I'm not going to stay in the lighting.
She's just she's just in the corner.
No, she's not asleep.
She's just in the corner.
Wide awake.
I'll go back.
It's from back.
I'm going to have to need a coat of that money.
What?
Well, I'm like, I don't have money.
The one you earn from my fight.
I lost money.
I'm very bad.
Yeah.
He was one of the battle.
Wrong version.
I know that.
Who better me winning?
Daniel.
I bet five bellies.
10,000 bellies on you that proves how much he trusts you.
That's scary.
You're going to trust him.
Yeah.
You're forgetting.
I saw day more.
I saw that with my eyes.
That is in Choubet.
I thought you bet.
Daniel probably only got five.
I'm not sure.
Yeah, but you only gave five bellies because you didn't bet 10.
Yeah, I only bet five bellies with Daniel.
So he will only get five.
So he didn't get the five anyway.
I don't know.
All right.
That tastes what you were saying.
I had told Bob that she's not asleep.
He's still one of them.
The plan was when she would go to sleep.
I don't know.
Well, what's the new plan now?
All right.
So this is.
I got.
Like if she does not.
If she does not go to sleep, then you have to force it away from her.
We can't just sneak it away.
Yeah, what's the.
Yeah, I'm not going to.
That's a bad.
You'll need to get me downstairs somehow and get my fat ass back up.
Okay.
So I can.
Oh, only if we had lit.
I can be like I'm going to give you some food here.
All right.
Yeah, she's going.
Even if she doesn't go to it.
Like a lot of cage put me in there with her.
I just can't touch the bag, right?
No, I just knock her ass out.
Just walk my.
So you want to make her like an enemy like.
No, because still now she does not consider that as that much of it.
She hasn't told us shit.
Like what do you want?
What do you want to get her yet?
We need the journal.
Yeah.
Change of plans.
We'll just stick with the interrogation.
Or hear me out.
Vote for book.
She already said no, but for book.
She wants to live.
She wants.
She needs to get there.
Vote for book.
Final offer.
I mean, you can go top to her again.
I mean, why.
Books for her life.
I mean, she will leave at one point or other.
She can.
Yo, that's, that's pretty good.
I might, I might just use this.
The more time we waste, the more strength we're allowing her to get.
She's not going to get tired.
I'm not the tooth fairy.
I cannot make her sleep.
What are you going to do to her?
Lala, bye.
I want you to shoot a spell that's going to play soft, meditating music.
That's going to put her in a sleep.
Putting people to sleep is usual, dude.
I will.
I'm already on set.
Yeah, I'm still arguing with him.
Okay, uh, uh, guy.
Here's my proposal.
Yeah, what do you say?
You're an interrogation guy who doesn't interrogate.
You can't put somebody to sleep.
What good are you for?
I can make people happy day.
You can't make people happy day.
You try that on me.
I'll do that for your ass.
I'll do that for you.
Okay.
Bob.
You got one you you either go downstairs and get that notebook or I'm throwing you off the ship.
Okay.
Look, there's my proposal.
Here's my proposal.
Let's uh, can we wait for her to sleep and just keep and watch on her?
Because she's going to sleep in our later, right?
Bob.
I don't know if you don't if you don't get back to East at no book by morning.
I hope you know your C-Shanties because I'm going to put you on one of those little boats and I'm going to send you off.
You're doing your job.
You're used to be a minister interrogator, but you can't interrogate.
Look, interrogation comes later.
We're not talking about interrogation.
What the fuck?
We can interrogate later, but we're talking about feeling the journal.
We're talking about getting it for us.
Right.
And for that, she needs to sleep or you guys are going to have to take it by force.
So, do you wait for her to sleep or what?
I'm for to take it by force, but you guys said no.
Yeah, because that will make her an enemy.
I'm just giving you the fact you need to choose for yourself.
Do you make her an enemy and like, oh, guys plan.
That's what I'm saying.
Well, we're arguing. I want to see what Baptiste is doing.
Yeah.
I'm going to be quiet now.
I want to hear what Baptiste does.
God, she is hot.
What?
Do not see your little token.
She was hot.
What the talking?
All this moment I was looking at the spider over here and I thought that was the token for her.
Did that mean?
I was thinking why is that hard for Roma?
Okay.
I'm walking back down.
As you walk in, she just gets up from,
like from where she was sitting down and she walks up.
Yeah.
Did you eat?
I'll look at the plate.
No.
You didn't have in touch it.
You don't eat.
You don't sleep.
Almost as if you think I trust you.
And you expect us to trust you by blending you are.
I'm not asking you to trust me.
I'm just asking for an exchange.
That's all.
I offered you change and you used.
What? What exchange?
You just trapped me in the cell like a prison.
Looking out.
Help us.
And we help you get back home.
Don't seem to understand that I don't care about your trial or whatever you going through.
I have my own things to deal with.
I need to leave now.
And how about we exchange information for information?
I don't need information.
I need to get out of here.
Are you not an informant?
I'm informed.
I already got whatever you guys did.
Have someone understanding?
If I provide you information.
That you did not already have.
You will give me.
It depends if it's valuable to me.
Do we have a deal?
We have a deal.
Go ahead.
I want information.
I want to give her.
Tell her how the island blew up.
Tell her what's going on with you get industries.
How to grab those documents.
How is journal.
Journal and all the documents regarding what was going on on the island.
Taking those so I could give them to a reporter.
Yeah.
And then I'll hand all those over to her.
You want to hand them over.
You want to throw them down in the cell.
The way you just word that makes me not.
I'm just asking for behavioral purpose.
You will hand them over.
So you hand the journal with some blueprints and stuff like that.
Do you just want to hand the journal?
The journal and all the documents regarding what was going on.
So everything.
The only thing you got from there was the blueprint of the island itself and the journal.
Nothing else about how the components are made or anything like that.
I thought we talked about some of the ledgers.
Yeah, you did you did you did get the ledgers of the shipments from one island to another.
Like some leading to some blue some leading to some place else.
You can hand them over.
Yeah, I would explain what he is doing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In this journal there was all of it was explained as that is all the windows.
Yeah, I'll hand it over.
So you have the shipment and the blueprints and the journal, right?
She takes it like as it snatches.
Essentially she takes it.
She goes like two of corners with like some light through the window and she flips it over.
She looks at it she reads it as she's reading it.
You see her eyes kind of widening kind of understanding it and just quickly read through the rest looks at the blueprints and the ledgers.
She goes, the hell is even happening.
How did you get this?
I told you.
The island will walk.
Well, only Baptiste is there so.
I know, I know it's just been hilarious.
I want to craft me for more information than what I'm already giving you.
Well, you have me convinced.
So what do you want?
Starting with where he's at currently.
The last whereabouts as far as I know he was spotted somewhere in the north blue flying towards the south blue.
A marine outpost sign.
You see a marine output saw him yet you want to give this information to the Marines.
This information.
What information.
You asked about his whereabouts you didn't ask what information I gave you that now tell me.
How do you have this?
Because we put a stop to.
Don't do it.
Okay.
Wow.
What did you even know how to blow this thing up?
The I just have two questions.
So I get to my own.
Here I go ahead.
What information were you going to get some reads?
See now I'm putting myself at risk if I tell you that.
So I get to ask two more questions.
Or I will put myself at risk to ask you another question.
We're trusting each other right?
Okay.
They wanted to know if he was accompanied by one of the other members of the sixfold or not.
And they see.
No.
I get to ask one more question than you can ask that.
Okay.
My question, which will probably put you at risk.
What crew do you belong to?
My overall crew or my personal crew?
No.
I know I've seen you somewhere.
I just want to confirm.
That you do work for the one that I think you work with.
Which is.
A black hand fired himself.
Well, you'd be right.
She nods.
He goes back.
So.
Go ahead.
What was the question?
Was there a clip another sixfold member?
Make sure you want to ask that question.
What was.
I assume if I ask you who you're going to ask another question as well.
What?
Will you tell me who or do I have to answer another question of yours?
Now you have to answer another question.
So.
If I'm not wrong, what is your name?
I didn't do something so funny right now.
Say Bob.
No, you need to know the question.
You cannot do that.
That's not funny.
Go ahead.
The other one another.
I'm back to.
That's the same up taste.
Who was there about eight years ago?
That's a question.
Okay, well, I don't need you to answer that.
I think I already know.
You know, I ever I.
I always wanted to know this though.
What are you?
You're not human and don't pretend that it's your devil for them.
Okay, go ahead.
Who of the six folks was there with?
You was with Liz.
Marrow.
You said Harrow.
Liz Marrow.
You just asked me another question.
Did you not?
Did what are you?
If I were to answer that question, I'd be putting my address.
So I need three questions in return.
No, you can ask me a question that would put me in a dress.
Or I could ask three.
No, that's not how it works.
You said the rules.
You said earlier when you get to ask two questions for putting yourself at risk.
No, because I think I've given mostly everything that I want except for that.
And I'm not speaking anything.
I'm not saying anything unless you answer that.
You know, you know, being a so plan was.
Yeah, I'm not stupid.
I'm an informant.
The only valuable thing on me is this notebook.
And then she shows you the notebook with blank pages.
That wasn't the plan.
Okay, what was it?
Oh, wait, blank pages.
Yes.
Of course, you're not going to fucking have like everything she knows in a fucking notebook.
Yeah, we don't we ain't going to know anything about this.
Bob, we still have to argue about your users.
I was just confirming blank pages.
Yeah, good.
Go ahead, that is.
It was either you die or you give us information with them.
I chose.
To let me live.
You want me to gravel now?
Gravel.
For my life.
Is that your attempt to threaten me?
I'm not threatening me at all.
I'm not threatening you.
Like you said, you're in the cage.
What can you do?
Can I do indeed?
But I would like to be on a good network with you, which is why.
I have come down here.
So.
You don't send her free.
I'm not.
I did not say that.
You asked me a question.
I never lose my answer.
You may be able to help me as well.
So I asked my question and give you your answer at the same time.
Okay.
Do you have?
What?
Do you have any information on any of the marines?
Interesting.
Or.
Marines.
Makes sense.
That's how.
You escape that place.
Hmm.
She starts to like walk around and.
Uh, starts to think to herself and just mumbling.
You can't really make anything out of it.
She stops.
Turn around.
She goes.
Hmm.
Okay.
Can you ask her a scape?
What do you mean by escape?
I'm pretty sure I know what she's talking about.
Yeah.
Uh.
So you were the one.
What about the other two?
I don't know.
Unfortunately, I can't help you with that.
The only thing I know is that there have been.
Only two sightings of a Lunarion.
One.
When you probably know that one.
The other was a few months back.
In the North blue.
You're going to have more specific.
One of the marine posts.
Apparently some Lunarion escaped.
Even more specific.
That's all the information I have.
Unfortunately.
I believe we're done.
No, we are not.
I'll walk out.
Okay.
You can't keep me trapped here forever.
Uh.
I'm just waiting for him to return.
So you got anything.
I'll start relaying everything that I just got from.
See also.
In the North blue.
As he comes up the stairs, all he hears is me about.
Yeah.
We are.
We can't get into the gate.
We can not.
Any information out of.
If we don't enter again.
One of your news.
There's no other way.
You're as much to fight in your hand.
You pissed me off.
You're what are you good for mom?
Could you do shut up for a moment?
What?
Oh, I'm back.
Okay.
Sorry.
I have a piece.
What?
What's going on?
Okay.
No, we'll enter it out here too.
Up on the mess.
They probably cannot hear you from this point from this.
Okay.
Well, jump down.
If he says to show it,
sorry, could just keep a little powder.
I'll be back.
So did you get anything out of her?
I'll start relaying information.
Okay.
He's with Liz.
But he was already with Liz.
What?
She's one of the other members.
No, he left with Liz.
So that couldn't be the sixfold they were talking about because that information is already known.
What's sixfold she was talking about?
Fine.
Maybe.
But did they found them or not?
She said she lied to me.
What were the questions you asked?
I asked her who among the sixfolds.
No.
Okay.
Let me recap.
So you asked her.
Was she accompanied by another sixfold?
She said, yes, which is true.
You asked her who it was.
She said the name.
And it was true.
So she technically did not lie because you asked the wrong question.
Down there.
We have it.
We'll follow you in at this point.
Right.
So you put the black hole.
Are you sure?
Yes.
And I'm stuck into it.
So she swam against the table.
Oh, God damn.
Okay.
Let me make a DC 12.
Sure.
And she's not that strong.
So she might lose.
She is apparently.
That just makes her like not fall.
Yeah.
She won't be on the fail.
Creatures take 24 and pull 10 feet.
The surroundings do smash to each other.
So it's like everything in the in the cell is like.
And everything falls.
She does feel the pole.
And she goes, what's wrong with you?
You think it's not her fault.
Sorry, Baptiste.
I'm sorry.
I will go.
I've been faced with being called mouth is so.
Is that.
You basically the same.
All right.
Don't be too anxious.
I'm sorry.
All right.
Go ahead.
What will we say?
When we find his sister,
you're going to make her up with us too.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Is that all this is the same?
Uh, you know what we're saying?
You think you're so clever.
What?
I don't use the truth.
And I also you still left me here in the cell.
So we never agreed on how we agreed on exchanging information.
And I told you the truth.
I never said you lied.
I said you thought you were.
You think you're clever, don't you?
Yeah, now you're throwing a change from.
Tell me something I don't know.
Who was very clear.
Let's see this kind of information.
Is expensive.
Maybe a boat's worth expensive.
Maybe your life's worth expensive.
Look, if I was worried about you killing me,
I would have killed myself at this point.
You don't value your life at all.
No, I want you to value my information.
It is my life.
Sounds pretty depressing.
Yeah, tell me about it.
I don't want to hear it from a pirate anyway.
Do you think I have much choice of where I can go knowing.
I definitely want one.
All of the world don't maintain me, but.
I have my reasons you have yours.
And we are the sense though.
The only way I will give you the information that you now very much want is.
Give me the book.
I'll go my separate ways.
I will tell you what I know.
That is where you're confused.
I don't want that information as much information.
I wanted you said you didn't have.
Well, it's behind you as he goes.
We do know he's heading to the south.
So do we want to cross the.
I mean, first of all, we need to get some place that we may get another boat.
To go to the south.
Find who first.
Our boat.
We need to find the way.
That's how.
Where there's a will.
Okay.
It's a will right there.
We knew the direction.
We just have to.
Hope to follow the.
I mean.
We're going to the same direction, but the lock poses don't really.
We're going to go to the south.
I don't know if you're going to do the same place anymore.
That boat has some things we need.
We can't.
Until we get it.
That boat back.
Yeah, but wait a second.
Or my supplies on the boat to.
If so.
We're going to go check something so he runs away.
Goes back to Serica.
Okay, you can continue.
Docking if you want to.
Yes, that's.
I thought you could be friends.
You really don't know you form.
I really don't know.
Sluts.
Well, you.
Oh, please.
Damn.
Yeah.
What you find out.
Hey, Roman.
Yes.
If you find a way down there, you can smack her as much as you want.
All right.
I'm.
Okay, so that's me.
Right here.
Well, so that means there's no making friends.
We're just taking the journal by four.
The journal's blank.
There's nothing.
I mean, we could.
Oh, all right.
Wait, what?
It might be blank to you.
I don't know if my decent spell or something.
More Roman will get it anyway.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, wait, I'm going to go with Roma in the break.
All right.
So, Malfa, still have anything to say for the information that he's just told you?
Yes.
The North Blue side.
It might be referring to me.
I know it said near a marine base.
You would know where near a marine base.
At least no one saw you.
Well, you said I was like, yeah, we're in stuff.
I was there.
Yeah, no, it's an outpost.
An outpost is different than like the people that saw you.
Those people don't didn't know that you were Lunaire.
Also sure.
Yeah.
Turn back.
We weren't in our bro earlier.
Is she armed?
No, she had one blade that will through a way.
So she's on.
She can deal you one kind of.
Hmm.
No, no fucking.
No, like, no, like, no.
She hasn't had food.
She's been drowning.
She's been.
She's on the verge of sleep.
Oh, I'm a wack.
Shit out of it.
Yeah.
I mean, she's very professional, to be honest.
Very.
She's in a cage, bro.
So, mouth as you want to talk to you about peace or no.
I think you're almost very excited to do smack.
Okay, okay, go ahead, don't.
Right.
I'm going to take my skillet, running across the cage and be like,
all right, madam.
Not this moron again.
Okay, and you start spilling or I'ma start smacking.
You got five seconds.
All right, Bob.
You know, I've been interrogated by Marines, right?
And pirates, you think you're different?
You think you can make me talk?
I'm just not really.
I'm not really.
No, but I am willing.
If my captain says you got information,
do you want giving it?
I will do anything in my power to get that information.
Right.
Just be it on it, but you.
I ain't trying to scare you.
I'm just telling you.
I ain't got time to waste.
Like you got five seconds.
I'm just trying to do that.
A persuasion or a deception based on what you're trying to do.
And do that in.
I mean, I guess you do that just here.
I don't know why I'm doing that.
I'm just being honest.
All right.
I'm going to be just fucking her up.
Do persuasion check for me.
Just normal.
Okay.
I'm just going to be doing that.
Is she intimidating?
She believes you.
Is she intimidated by you?
That's what I want to check.
No.
All right.
She's just sitting there.
I'm not doing anything.
You met him.
That that journal that you have.
I.
My friend said that you said that's the most important thing on you.
Why?
Okay.
Let me tell you something.
This has nothing.
Okay.
As you can see.
I was just a bluff.
Yeah.
Do an insight.
I'm not going to be able to say that.
Oh god damn it, where's my fucking pan? There it is.
Oh I forgot to do it with a manage.
Yeah, do...
I got it again.
Oh my god, did you save that?
Alright, you swing. Do the damage.
Oh my god, okay.
That is going to knock her out.
Unless I save this.
Depending.
Okay, yeah, she saves.
Oh, you wanna save something?
So...
Do you do a roll?
DM?
Yes, I did do a roll.
16.
She's a thief.
Yes.
Okay, then silver barbs.
Okay, you wanna make it again?
Yeah, I'm gonna use my...
She still succeeds.
Okay, the weapon hits her.
The blood sports out of her mouth, but she still stays up and on her move, she's gonna
try to grapple you.
Yeah, once she has something that she can use to grapple you.
Okay.
It's strength or athletics.
I think it can be both, right?
To grapple.
To graphics.
Oh, it's athletics.
Yeah.
To grapple, it's like athletics, but to escape is a lot of core acrobatics.
Oh, she's a giant.
Oh no, you did it recklessly.
You're in grappling a pull up there.
Is it attacks that you have advantage on or is it everything?
Yeah, it's only a text.
Okay, it's only a text.
Well, you see, she pulls out something from her back and she tries to like slap that
on your wrist, but you just duck out of the way and she just rolls down.
She falls on the ground.
And now...
Can Roma grapple her?
No, no, she gets up too.
She gets up quickly, but she was trying to cuff you with these cuffs that she's holding
in her hands.
Oh, see, please.
Shit.
Can I yell out on my turn?
Can I yell out to Roma?
Gratul her quick.
Like, can I advise him to grapple her?
Okay.
Why not just knock her out?
Yeah.
I'm going to move you guys in.
Then to combat at this point, but Roma, you will go first.
I can just take the back right out of her hand and probably the cuffs if you manage to
grapple her because the cuffs are a problem to you, but not me.
But what I'm saying though is I could just knock her out and you could have the cuffs.
Like, if you grapple her, then I can immediately make you succeed.
But if you knock her out, then there might be a swing though.
It's up to you, but I'm trying to figure out what.
Alright, do it.
She's the lowest ranking of us.
Yeah.
Shut up.
Alright.
Crazy.
Normal.
That's the first one.
Does that hit?
No.
That hits.
Okay.
Here comes the second one.
Oh, it doesn't matter if you're doing neatly, not neatly.
If it hits, then it fills it.
Okay.
Just making sure.
But what is he trying to knock her out?
Yeah, but if it's like too much damage, if it's twice as much as their full HP, she's
going to die.
Well, you're telling me Roma can do twice her HP in one attack?
She's not like a pirate.
I did four days.
Oh, yeah.
That should be able to knock her out.
That's it.
Yeah.
She's down.
Alright.
Well, I'm going to take a Cuffs.
You try to take on me.
Stick them on her.
And then normal touch them.
No touch.
Yeah.
As soon as you touch them, you just lose all your friends.
You fall to the ground.
But she is not that way from away from him so that he gets his strength back.
Okay.
But she is not that.
Yeah.
Let's just hand cover for now.
And let's take the bag.
So like once he takes it, do I have all my strength back or is there like a certain
time?
Yeah.
As soon as it's like away from you, you kind of regain your strength.
Perfect.
Cause I know exactly what I'm doing.
I'm going to grab her.
I'm going to come back over here.
I'm going to be like, alright, hoist me up.
Hello.
Who's going to.
I can't take the bag before he does that.
You already did.
You already said you grabbed it.
I said you grabbed it.
You said you grabbed it.
Okay.
Let's say you have the bag.
Yeah.
And you move her here.
Okay.
Yeah.
How big is the hole?
It's enough to get you through.
Like basically, mouth is size whole.
Is that it?
That's it.
No, what I'm saying is like how far like down?
Like it, is it like a 10 foot?
Yeah, it's probably like 10, 10 to 15 feet.
So if I, if I reach with my arms up, can't I just pull myself up?
No, no.
Shouldn't be that much because you still have to jump.
Do even get to the point, but you can't jump like on six feet.
Yeah, that's well, that's what I'm saying.
If it's only 10 foot, I'm like eight or nine foot tall.
I could just jump up grab like the railing.
I think it works based on like how like it based on your strength.
How far can you jump?
Is it not?
It's your half your half your movement, right?
Jump.
Hi.
Let me see.
I don't say strength because that's my highest.
Jump high, the calculator, I adding your strength modifier to the number three, three plus your strength.
What is it?
Three plus 15 would be 18.
No, no, modifier, not not the.
Oh, so be five.
Five feet.
Yeah, you can only jump up to five feet.
Okay, so we're going to say it's like 20 feet tall.
No, it's 15 feet, but you still can jump to that height.
Oh, well, we're spilling him up.
Who's getting me out?
Y'all said you're going to get me out.
Get down.
Yeah, and I've changed my mind.
I'm going to get you out of here.
I got it.
You guys got five seconds before I kill her.
Yes, I was pulling him up.
Go on.
We'll try to pull him up.
Okay, both of you just make a strength check.
I'll take the average.
No, okay.
Nobody can put you up to it.
Oh, my God.
So you both try to pull him up and you cannot.
You just lose him as you're trying to grab him.
No, it's not that high.
He won't take any damage, but yeah, you just drop him down.
But you do follow your ass.
Get the brick fist, dude. He could pull my ass up.
Yeah, I mean, you fall down.
There should be enough commotion.
Then walks up.
He goes.
He just grabs you.
Okay, he grabs you.
It throws you up.
If decks, a mocha decks save a Baptist or anyone of you.
If you succeed, I'll say that you able to just pull him up halfway.
He throws you halfway.
Halfway.
These guys can pull you up.
And he just.
And he's going to take the other one.
The other one.
You can go.
Okay.
And then he goes.
The other one.
and
all right Cheng
I need you to fly up, fly this other end up and go around the mast, but to the point where she's hanging out by the water.
Okay, so when I hang around here somewhere.
Yep, yep, yeah.
I'm a hold on to this rope and then you can question all you want and then I'm going to drop her.
Okay, who's holding on to the rope and who's like throwing her off the mast?
Roma, you're holding a rope who's throwing her off the mast?
Can I yell out to Roma?
Dude, I know you're really excited about this, but can we do the questioning part tomorrow?
Please, because it will be beneficial to all of us.
It will actually help.
I can actually help you if we do this tomorrow.
Otherwise, we'll just need to cross her words.
Is she going to survive that long?
I mean, it's just up until the morning.
That's fine.
She's just going to hang here to work, but that's just a dick move.
Yeah.
I mean, whatever you've been doing so far is a dick move.
Okay, that's not pretend.
That's anything good is happening here.
I need to kill people.
I don't believe in torture.
So no prolonged torture, this killing just offer up.
Okay, cool.
Yeah, exactly.
Like you all need information.
She doesn't tell you I'm dropping her.
She's in handcuffs. She ain't going to be able to swim.
No, the handcuffs is on him.
We can't enter get her tomorrow.
Would you let her just hang here?
No, you there's a break for we have a break.
I don't know.
We got her tied up.
We got her dangling.
And then now you want to say put her back.
It's too late now.
I'm going to get her tied up.
The point that was to get the journal.
At this point, we'll we'll drop down and go.
Roma, what the hell are you doing?
Let her go.
What is wrong with you guys?
I don't know.
Don't let her go.
Wait.
She's falling in the ocean.
Don't let her go right now.
Oh, shit.
If you do whatever,
if you let her go, we'll catch it.
But like, I was told to kill her.
This way we still get the information.
And if she says she gives us good information,
we give her a damn boat.
And tell her to get the fuck out of here.
I'm damn it.
That's just.
If she doesn't have to get the rope,
she dies.
We keep going.
Okay, uh,
Bobby's going to look at everyone and.
Okay, guys, Roma is very excited right now.
I don't care if he's excited.
We're going to skywalk.
Grab her, got the rope.
And she's going to just grab her and put her down here.
Okay, I don't know what you guys are up to.
But you can't do this.
Okay, we don't torture people.
I think we don't torture people.
And as long as we're with you guys,
you have to.
You know, what?
I just wanted to get the information and give her a boat.
What?
Okay, the owner.
Look, I know.
I don't want you guys to hurt her.
Okay, interrogation is fine.
Don't hurt her.
This isn't the way to do things.
Roma, I'm just trying to make it look like we're going to do it.
Come on now.
It's going to get the.
She's leading because she can give us good information.
I had a wake her a couple of times.
Now, if it's that teased, can you handle this or no?
The other part on the other way or at no,
like, what is this?
I'm going to say, okay, guys, like if you invest in interrogate her tomorrow,
like trust me, interrogate her tomorrow,
and then you can do whatever you want.
But I can help that way.
Then he'll just going to go on the spot and start investigating the journal.
Roma just leave it for tomorrow.
Hey, what do you, you guys hungry?
Shit, that worked up an appetite.
Where is probably going to throw her right in the book?
Lock the door and he's going to toss the keys to you,
but again, and he just goes.
Look, I, I understand she fooled you,
but you have to keep your guys in check.
Like, you just have him just do anything.
You left here.
What?
You let there could do anything.
Yeah, but I keep it in check at the way he needs you could have both.
Rome is half off.
I keep him in check when I need to as well.
No, you go, don't you have woman.
And just going to let it happen unless I stepped in.
I know the limits.
Maybe I was wrong about you.
Okay, he's just going to run up onto the mast.
So what?
Well, the Korean drama.
All right, all of this emotion would probably wake Daniel up.
He probably walks up to you down the deck.
It goes.
It's 12 p.m.
Can you guys just go to sleep so we can get to work tomorrow?
We were just about to go.
Okay, just don't stop making that fucking.
Rock us.
What's the word?
What?
Nothing.
Night time.
I'm going to go to the gym.
So I do want to skip to morning.
Okay, do an investigation check.
I'm going to.
Okay, before doing that, like what do I see from the outside?
It's just blank.
All the pages are blank.
Yeah, there's no nothing.
Okay, so before my investigation check,
check magic as a ritual to see if anything,
any kind of spell or anything is affecting and making a blank or anything.
Anything magical, correct?
Yes.
Okay.
Has to take magic.
No.
Yeah, okay, so nothing magical.
And the only magic sources that you can sense through your sensors is coming from Bob,
Circle, well,
Baptiste and from the sea prison cuffs that you hold and from the fucking bag.
Okay, so let's just go normal like investigators way like if there's like some kind of line.
I'm going to do an intent on a investigation check.
I'm going to use my last port to use of the 90 and I.
12th six to investigation.
So I get it 25.
Let me check.
Yep, that's not enough for anything because there's nothing to check.
It's actually blank.
Well, it was worth it.
But okay, so that's did you said that was not enough for the use?
No, it's blank.
Okay, so everything she knows is in her mind.
So that needs to wait for tomorrow.
I'm going to go to sleep.
Oh wait, before before that.
Can I check on my card?
You find a name and address in loatown.
You find another set of sea prison cuffs and that's that's about it.
Do I recognize the name or the address?
No, Mr Says loatown at the end.
So you recognize that because that's where she wants to go.
Oh, all right.
Okay, so I go to sleep.
Okay, do a long rest, everyone.
Joke up again and things about the new thing then ghost sleep again and then things of the new thing again.
Yeah, do a long rest, everyone.
Yeah, you still tied up, right?
You didn't remove the ropes.
And those real dead.
No, I don't think so.
I just cut the rope.
She said tied up in the break.
All right, it's morning time.
You can have your fight if you want to or have I completely do it.
Yeah, I'm just going to get back to that.
So is it 9% for that little puzzle thing?
13 and 9.
Yeah, rule again.
Intelligence.
Oh, electricity one way.
What what went away?
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, go ahead.
But do it's going to do at this point.
Yeah, I think I'm going to go to the back.
I think I'm going to go to the back.
What is it a lie detector?
Yeah, basically.
Yes, I'm a machine, right?
I'm a machine.
So yeah, really expensive lie detector.
So you bring her back up onto the deck.
Yes, again, she.
As you go down to get her, you don't really see a reaction from her.
You ask her to get up, I guess, and she just walks up onto the deck.
Make her walk the plank.
Roma.
Not today.
Oh, come on, Baptiste.
Let's have some fun with her.
You had a Roma.
You have to do it last night.
What you mean, I didn't get to do anything.
That was good.
Did he almost kill her?
I didn't almost kill her.
I just walked her a couple times.
She's not.
Well, plus 9% then.
Yeah, that's a snake.
Yeah, what were you saying, Baptiste?
We're taking a different approach today.
You know what?
Oh, my God.
That's funny.
Good, good, good.
We're saying.
Your freedom is.
We're letting her go.
Okay, I see you cut the ropes.
She wouldn't.
Okay, okay, cool, cool, cool.
All right, if we are to let you go.
We just need that one last piece of information.
And what's gonna like cast detect thoughts on the girl?
Hey, detect thoughts.
What does it do?
Does it tell you like exactly what they're thinking?
Or is it a wag?
No, firstly, no, firstly, it will just give me whatever is on the surface.
But it's for interpretation like.
Can you guys hear him all out here?
No, he's dying.
Yeah, it's nice.
I think he does direct the target's creatures thoughts.
So you want to read the surface thoughts and you don't want to hear the in depth thoughts for the in depth thoughts.
You need to make the distance a right?
Yeah, can you guys hear me?
Yeah, yeah.
Also, the detect thoughts is good.
At first, it will just give me her surface level thoughts.
The thing she's thinking about the most without it saved.
So it's good for interrogation because like if she's asked a question, her thoughts would think about that.
And I'll I'll be that.
But if I want, I can make her do a safe to probe deeper into her mind.
Okay, Bob, I'm gonna send you in the DMs what she's thinking of right now.
But if you want to communicate it with the other people, you'll have to either whisper to them.
Or if you want to just say what she's thinking, you can also do that.
But I'm just gonna DM you so no one else actually knows what she's thinking.
Okay, so as you say, you're gonna free her, but you need the information about like who was accompanying with other than Liz.
Or if he if he was being accompanied by anyone other than Liz, Bob, this is what you hear.
You have something down here.
Is that what I hear?
No.
Because I need her to rewind that. I just don't understand a single thing.
That's what you hear on surface level.
I'll just signal him to go on.
Like I have the questions.
He does not really respond to you.
She just looks at her hands and that's it.
Think about enough is going to be able to get you back home.
It doesn't seem like you can take care of yourself.
I've been taking care of myself my whole life.
So you don't need to worry about me.
You're lucky they saved your life.
Give them what they want.
It's completely different when you're sailing the seas, especially with CB's from me.
Dude, don't try to reason with her. Just ask her the question.
She is beyond reason.
What question?
So you're telling him in.
No, wait, wait, are you saying that to Baptiste?
Yeah, I'm telling him to keep asking her the question.
She is beyond reasoning.
She knows that you want him to ask the question for some reason.
Just say it now.
All right, but I'm going to read her thoughts.
Yeah, that's fine.
Outside of Liz.
I'm trying to think of something.
Yeah, I'm driving.
I'm driving.
She's not saying anything.
I love she just looking at Bob.
She's very suspicious of what both of you are trying to do.
I'm not playing what it worked better.
Okay, so.
Okay, here is since he asked the question.
Even.
Okay, even if she's thinking about that like outside should probably have something like.
Conscious.
And response to the question.
So I'm going to probe deep.
And what do I do?
I use my port and also very far.
You know what I'm going to probe deeper into our mind.
Let's make her do the same.
Go first.
Well, she failed.
Okay, she fails.
And.
I'm inside your mind now.
Like I'm inside.
Yeah, I'm a mind goblin.
I would hate for you to get into Roma's mind.
It's going to be food and slaughtering.
I'm going to look at her.
Look at Baptist and say.
She needs to help someone.
Like allowed so that she hears that.
And so that I could somehow in her subconscious make her think about that thing more by saying it.
So I'm going to say she needs to save someone and she needs to get get back.
Okay, she now knows that you can in.
For some reason can read minds.
Okay, question.
We're ready to add the creature.
Okay, so for how long can you hold a subconscious?
One minute.
So I hope.
Yeah, go ahead.
You don't have a lot of time.
I hope we can do this quickly.
Who is it?
Yeah, after I said that, do I do anything?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, after Baptist said that, do I see anything?
Let me see.
Okay, that's what you hear.
Okay, that's surface level thoughts, but I'm like probably.
Listen, listen.
Now that's the mind that's all she's thinking of right now.
She's flooding her thoughts with just that.
So that's only there's never need to say die and give us information.
Only.
Bob, you're cutting out.
Think I hear.
You cut out for everything you said.
I got that's what you're here.
I do a DM just one thing after probing deep.
I will.
Oh, sorry.
DM I was DM I was just one thing.
If something that looms large in her mind, something she worries over loves or hates.
So is that she loves or hates?
I said she was something.
Just read.
Yeah, but.
Oh, right.
Oh, oh, oh, I'm going to yell out she knows after.
She needs to save after.
Since veil knew after I'm going to yell out to veil she needs to save after she needs to get back to.
He rushes over to her and just at this point he's just had enough.
Slams her down onto like the deck with her neck like completely tied down goes speak before I.
Snap your neck in half.
Old words for someone who was just complaining about methods yesterday.
Why do my dude move like.
What the fuck is going on?
Like you're just.
Saka.
All right.
Well, also step in.
She goes.
Stay the fuck back if you don't want to die.
All right.
And she's going to point her guns to you guys.
If you will, like try to intervene in this conversation.
I want to see the bloodshed.
Let's go.
You're right.
I wasn't.
Do do do do do.
Please.
We can't do this again.
Okay.
So what is that?
No one's intervening.
Can I can I.
I don't think I have the.
I don't think I have that much time.
So can I do one last try.
Is there gonna be any kind of flashers of how what state he is in or anything like is he worrying about him like?
About to die or no nothing like that.
It's not like life or death. It's like she thinks he's already dead.
She thinks she's already dead but there's a way to save him. That's what she's thinking.
In between this, do you understand?
Just stay back and let me handle this. No, it's well.
I'm getting in between. We just need to collect all the information.
But I'm with it. Snap her fucking neck.
I'm gonna yell out guys. If we do this, she's shown trust us.
You need that right now.
You need to win her trust. Okay, because it is calling problems.
Seca's going to lower her guns down for once.
She puts her hand on Will's shoulder as she goes, you know, whatever she knows.
It won't matter. We've tried everything. It doesn't. It never works.
Will would relax his arms as he just throws her down and get up and gets back a bit,
like a bit worried looking at his hands, like flenches his fists as he moves back.
Can I?
I want to look at Bob and signal him towards Bale to try to read his mind.
Okay, I just want to make sure every person that you do this on, it's not wise to do it.
I know if I am trying to read the surface tasks and they won't know.
If I'm if I'm proving deeper, they'll immediately know.
Yeah, but you will communicate what you learn to map the extreme.
Yeah, go ahead.
I think it has already passed. It's not like it's all happened in like one minute.
It's already passed. You probably have already lost the grip on her in your thoughts.
Can Bob just say that he can't if I try to do that.
You want to do that? Bob, can you not cast it again?
I think you can.
Yes, I can, but we have a lot of information on our hands right now.
Like, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
I don't ever get to see somebody else get a snap of neck.
It's always me. God damn it.
Daniel will cheer like will kind of scream and these guys would kind of gather in as well.
Uh, to look as to what's happening.
Uh, where would hang a bit back and he'll just sit down and he can go.
Look, if you know, anyway, anything that can help him, just tell me to tell tell us you know, but
we care for him too.
You should know.
It was with us for two years.
Uh, she at this point is she's just rubbing her neck and
kind of worried that you might all kill her and like kind of worried about Bob too.
Yeah, can I come towards her and like first of all because I am very scared of her.
Can I hold my hands up and say I'm doing nothing.
Here's this cute little owl.
He is going to kill you.
So if you just wait and my owl will fly over and push on her shoulder and I'll cast
cure wounds.
Yes, sure.
Well, also Bob to take off her shackles since I can't touch them.
Uh, wait, wait, take off her shackles.
You know what?
Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, take it off and she just goes.
So just freeing me gives you the right to invade my mind.
Is that it?
No, but you do know that we you are an informant, right?
So you do know that in how interrogation goes.
Okay, you can't blame me for that.
And also I'm not in I'm not in your mind right now.
And then I heal her for.
Hmm.
I suppose I should just take your work for it then.
He gets up.
Uh, she looks at Baptiste.
She looks at the other two because.
All right.
I thought I would just take this through the grave, but I guess there's no way out.
But one thing you have to promise me is that you will let me go after I tell you this.
Tell us first.
Well, uh, uh, walk up to you, Baptiste and say,
just let her go if she tells us something useful than just let her go.
You know, this whole five-holder attitude you're having right now is really getting the
north.
You want to understand?
Uh,
she is wanting to information that probably he won't want to be he's civil and he
can't but.
It's reaching how he wants to feel.
Yeah, and he gets emotional too.
But he's a person still.
But I had an issue with us doing it.
Okay, we'll let you know.
All right.
I found a way to undo whatever happened to him.
It's just, it's just hard to get.
But I need to go back to love town, talk to my marine correspondent,
and maybe he will tell me to get that thing or how to retrieve that thing.
What is that thing or how?
It's storing some of one of the marine bases.
I don't know where.
That's what I need, need the information for.
But what is that thing?
It's a way to,
God damn it.
It's a way to permanently.
It doesn't have a name.
It's a device that removes the uses of the devil's fruit's ability permanently.
For a period of time.
Since I researched a lot on devil's force,
do I know that?
Do I need to do a check?
No.
No, you wouldn't know that.
You are learning about devil's fruit.
You don't know anything about devil's fruits.
This is the difference.
It's the start of your journey.
It's not the end of your journey.
Yeah, so you don't know anything about this.
This is the first time you've heard of it.
This is the first time anyone would have heard of it.
That's all I have.
It's a device that will permanently
disable the effects of a devil's fruit.
Well, at this point, it's kind of shocked and just steps back and it goes,
this might actually work.
But we have to find Verith first.
Why is Verith needed to help ask her?
You'll understand.
Okay, first we need that device.
First of all, we need Verith.
And then maybe we can get back as her.
You are not making any sense without...
Look, it's hard to explain.
What do you want me to do?
Okay.
Verith is not one person.
She didn't exist two years ago.
He's a different person.
And two people had to die to make Verith.
Well, die in like, I don't know, this is getting into philosophy.
I don't know anything about philosophy, but they're essentially dead.
They have mixed memories.
They care about people.
They know people.
They remember it, but they just don't remember that they're two people.
Was it that explosion?
Hardly.
There was a fruit that asked her, well, no, rolin found
in the North Blue like four years ago.
They used, rolin ate the fruit at some point.
They used to use that fruit to fuse.
But after the explosion, they just couldn't separate.
And it just got complicated.
We can't bring it up to them because they don't know.
They just don't...
They refuse to acknowledge that they're two people.
So we just pretend that they're not.
So, after and dear, it's our fused.
No, after and rolin are fused.
Verith is the new entity that they made.
Well, at first, when they fuse, they used to remember who they are.
But after the...
After Aralya died, it just broke something in them.
You just cannot remember anything.
So we are trying to find verith.
That means we're trying to find both rodent and ester.
Yes.
Well, that was not my plan. My plan was to go get rid and get
get our true back together.
Maybe we could go find line.
But...
Can I look at Zinn and say we are trying to find verith in...
I mean, in turn, rolin and ester as well.
So don't you need to ask that to happen?
What?
Saying that to Zinn, she goes...
Yeah, that's why I was keeping track on him too.
But I think getting the device is probably the hardest part.
Getting to him probably not that hard because most marines keep tabs on him.
Ah, it makes sense.
Daniel, big boy, you want some food?
You're all my coming in with no context whatsoever.
I think I've got that taste. What are we saying?
Was that so hard to explain?
I just don't want you guys to say anything that
would not make sense to him. Okay, it's just...
You guys don't need to know because you can't solve this problem.
We can solve this problem. Linus have been working for years to solve this problem.
But this...
Yeah, well, I'm as shocked as you are.
So if we all have the full goal...
And is there a reason that you still need to leave on your own Zinn?
Well, I still need to find the place and if I don't go back to
the marine correspondent, then you probably won't tell me where it is.
So you need to meet the marine?
Yes.
And then you need a deer.
Slash, ask them to remove the devil food ability.
Yes.
Do we have an extra log post anywhere?
Or didn't it mushy?
You have the radio?
How far does the radio work though?
Radio is like a radio wave frequency.
So it should work pretty far distance.
It's just different frequency as long as you're tuned into that frequency, it should work.
They'll give her the radio.
He tosses that radio to her, she catches it.
Goes with that.
Focus this thing.
It looks creepy.
It's the radio.
Didn't immerse you.
We'll be able to contact you.
We'll be fine, Ferris.
You contact us when you find information.
Can you call her so that she can save your number?
It's not a number, it's a frequency thing.
It's probably still tuned.
Yeah, it's tuned to the same frequency anyway.
Okay.
I mean, I think she's smart enough to understand.
Contact us if you need help.
Then we can obtain the item, then we can meet up and make sure that it's all done.
You can, right?
Okay, dude, can you give me my diary back?
You're what?
She looks at Bob.
Give me that back back.
Yeah, yeah, I'm going to give her back, but by the way, DM,
in her bag, there were two sea prism cuffs, right?
Now there's one.
You never know.
You never know when you might need it.
Okay.
You know, I'm going to do a perception just so.
I can, I got you.
She doesn't notice.
She's just going to take one sea prism cuff and the book back and put it inside.
As she goes.
I don't think I'll need you, but if I do, I will contact you.
So do we have a deal?
Are you willing to give me a ship?
A boat?
Now we're taking you to the next island, I thought.
I mean, it's probably easier for me to just get the boat and get going.
You're trying to get a bar on a small robot.
Exactly, you're going to try to survive this open sea where there's sea beasts and shit on a little robot.
I have my ways.
Just trust me.
I'm not going to the island.
Well, this point will step in and it goes.
Is that, is that the same diary that Astrid gave you?
She goes, she kind of nods and smirks a bit and goes, okay, she's fine.
Just let it go.
Once again.
By the way, the boats are in hours, right?
They belong to the six boats.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, they are not yours.
No, I mean, we'll see what happens then, but for now, yeah.
So what?
What?
You plan on leaving us in the dark again and what that
journal does, why you trust her so much to be able to be safe on her own?
Okay.
Remind me to go over all of the six fold abilities at some point with the OBAB T-St.
She pulls out like an ID card and he shows that ID card to you, of T-St.
Can I show this? Can I show this?
Yeah, there you go.
You see this?
Give me one second.
Are you not only fucking this?
Okay, let me know and you can see it.
Is she of drinking age?
I see veils.
You see a veils ID card, right?
Yeah, he hands this to you as he goes, okay, so this probably looks to you like a normal ID card.
It's not a normal ID card.
This was made by Liz.
Liz has the paper, paper fruit.
And she's pretty strong, like insanely strong.
So this is a way to track each and every one of us.
It also is a way so we can communicate with each other, not for long, but we can maybe talk
through it sometimes. We don't use it that much because then it uses all of our strength
to maintain the contact within each other for like the location stuff.
But essentially that's her ability.
She can control a piece of paper through any distance.
And when she makes something from her paper, you can just turn it to something and it actually
functions like an actual thing.
So as long as she has that paper in her hand, she will be able to make anything,
essentially, to get her out. And I think she has some idea to get out of here.
You're saying Liz can track you off through the papers?
Liz, yes. We on the other hand cannot.
So why hadn't she found all of you there?
She's with Virat. She doesn't need to find this.
Virat took her with... he took her. We'd never go on like individual missions. We always go in
Arabs up to... except for Lenin's not really a member.
I thought you guys wanted to find Virat. Can you just contact Liz and tell him to tell Virat to
come over or something? Virat told us to stay put in spirit cliffs. But seeing as Baptiste also
mentioned, we cannot stay there forever. We have to do something about... you know, getting our
crew together. So we just left. We're going to find Virat. And for, I don't know, last year we haven't
been doing anything and I think it's about time. We have... we do something about the things that
we left unfixed. And Virat for... I know he cares. I know he wants to do it all by himself, but I can...
I can't do that anymore. So we're going to find him. We're going to find all the rest of the members.
And we're going to get the crew back together. And we're going to get back to solving the problem.
And now as we know that all of this shit from Virat Lisa just falling back with the spiders and
in Bleszo and everything. With that, we have to clean up. We know there's two more locations.
Anyway, what I'm trying to say is just let her go. She's capable of handling herself with
Liz's paper. I have a couple pages which are now missing because I left it on the ship.
So...
We don't have the page, but we can like, you know, make something out of it to send it to them. Yeah.
But it's like a physical object, so it has to get to them.
It's probably faster than us, but you know... whatever.
Theoretically, we can just go with them. When we find the item, you can just send it through the paper to Liz.
Okay, now I mean, I don't know how the thing works, but why do we need to go back all the way to
the blue? Don't you guys have something to do here?
Or don't you not have it to sell blue to meet up with your commander? We need to find our ship,
first and foremost. Yeah, now I need to do because Liz won't kill me if I lost those papers.
So... I know it's a lot.
I'm kind of losing it right now, but trying to hold it all together.
Okay, Liz has the paper, paper, fruit. Ronan had the fusion, fusion fruit. They combined.
It all happened. I don't want to go through the whole fucking story. If you want to know anything
about the other members, I'll let you know. But for now, can we just go forward with her?
She can get to the informant. She can tell us what's up with that. How much time do you have for
that? She's gonna say like a week or so. Well, there you go. It's gonna take her a while to get
there, probably like three days. If you let any Marines know that we're coming, I'll find you.
She looks at you. She goes... Look, I hate the Marines as much as any other pirate.
Probably more so. That's all you need to say. Just keep it going.
But I'm gonna rat you out in one second. Do you understand me? He just points at you.
I don't throw a goddamn javelin through your little tiny boat.
What?
Can I trust you to keep the manners between us?
About the thing that we talked about, yes.
Look, I don't have anything against your kind. And I think whatever happened to you
in your kind is wrong. And I don't know these two six falls, but I kind of trust them. Although
this fucker almost killed me. But if he knows, I'll trust him. Look, just contact me if you find
worth first. I'll contact you if I have any information about the thing. If it's too hard for me to get
maybe we'll talk. So can I take my leave?
No, just one second. Just one second. I'm just gonna take my headphones.
Okay, go ahead. Go ahead. What were you saying?
Just making sure. So, I mean, we have a strange information, right? So the thing that you said before
about Vereth going from North blue to flying to South blue or something, was that actually true?
And can you get any more precise? Because you do know that we need to find it.
Yeah, everything I told you was true. He did not, he was not seen. Well, they were trying to
ascertain if Vereth found Klein or not, the Marines. But the last person who saw Vereth didn't have
any idea about whether he was with Klein or not, they only spotted two of the six falls on the
ship. So the answer for that is no. So what I'm guessing is he's headed to the South
because he has some information about Klein. So he might find Klein there. So your best bet is
to head to the South as well. All right, thanks.
As I say the fuck away from me, next time you get in my head, I'm gonna kill you.
Big sorry, it's for a little woman. Yeah, I'm not so little as she jumps around you and she
heads for the boat. Hey, take some food with you. I ain't gonna be an asshole.
She takes whatever your what do you have it in the skillet the blade what literally like a little
skillet thing. The fuck am I supposed to do with this? Just put in my bag?
Got to know it. Uh, Cole runs up to her and she goes, "Hey, Ledy, what do you think you're doing?"
Taking the boat. Yeah, that's not happening. What?
Yes, it is. He's gonna jump down and she's just gonna straight up look at you.
He's gonna go, "Is the Daniel approved of this?" No, Hugo asks him.
She shouts from this distance for Daniel. Uh, he, well, he will, he likes shouts, shouts.
What? When?
I didn't hear that honestly. He's gonna come up. He goes, "Okay, what's up?"
What's she doing with the ship with the boat? What are you guys doing?
I was looking at the mess that these fuckers were making. Okay, why is she taking the boat?
So she can go on her way?
Okay, so let me get this straight. For the last two days, you guys have fished
a stranger out from the ocean onto the ship, then you tortured her, beat her.
And are you letting her go? Orchard may be an overstayed man.
Whatever, you did beat her. Anyway, first, do not let me see, sleep. Second, you make a mess out of my
fucking ship. There's still a hole there. Now you want to take one of her two lifeboats.
Yeah, it's gonna take a while. It's like 10 minutes.
Did you want to start bending or no?
Okay, so as you're like taking planks, I don't know from where, but you're just fucking
flying that in. It goes, "That's not gonna help. Just use the different planks I have somewhere."
Oh my god. Then I'm gonna stop.
Then it goes, "Look, now honestly, just want all of you to disappear, but if even one of you goes,
I'm happy with that. But you're gonna pay me back for that repair and this boat."
Baptiste.
"Hey, you bet."
Yes.
He looks at... "Fair divides.
"Multi-time. Help do escape behind me."
Yeah, and for that, I am enduring your bullshit for the past week.
Don't get me started. Don't fucking get me started. Anyway.
Yeah, for a guy that dumb, you do speak a lot. Next time, make sure you understand what you're talking about.
First of all, understand this. "You mean nothing to me. You mean nothing to my boss. Those two are the ones we came for.
You were just in the way."
Okay, those two are the ones you look for. We still want Joe-ass.
And then in the process, save Joe-ass twice.
Yeah. Exactly. You came looking for us and got your ass what.
Like, this is all new. So that being said, we saved Joe-ass twice.
You are indebted to us currently.
And that is why you are on the ship. That is the only reason why.
What do you want? We're not counting this bullshit. Do you understand me?
Oh my god.
You do not talk to your captain. Do you?
Exactly. Do we have a deal? I'm out of the beast.
Well, no, no, I need your word.
Word on what except you're going to have to be specific.
Hey back.
Hey back on who? Doesn't matter. If we call you, you have to come to help us.
Now let's make it work, help! Oh my god!
You can't get hurt.
What?
Against anyone without. We'll help you get revenge on the doctor and the doctor alone.
Let's know how deals work.
Okay, I know what you're worried about. How about this? I'm not going to ask you against
going against the six falls. That clear? He puts her hand in front.
Anyone that I find an ally at any point, you cannot ask me to go.
You're making this deal like there's no repercussions.
Why would you help you? I don't understand.
If he doesn't know who you are, I would.
You obviously have a certain person in mind that you want our help in taking care of.
We don't. We much like the six falls we do get jobs from time to time.
I just don't want you to reneg on a job. That's all I want.
I'm saying, you're like you hunted us down but now you want our help.
Am I talking to you? No, I don't think so.
I'll just go ahead and...
You agree?
Not the six falls. Not the black hand pirates if you're worried about that. Sure, whatever.
Okay. Now, if you take one boat and that's it.
All right, Chloe, get back on top. Just keep an eye out.
If any Marines.
Well, at this point she looks around and she looks at drama as you guys.
Good to know. You're not an asshole just to me.
Looks at...
Oh, no, Jesus.
You see her take out like a few pages and she like makes like an origami drawing.
Wait, what?
No, sorry. Go ahead, Malfus.
Yeah. As the boat was lowering, I want to jump into it and ask you question myself.
What?
I want to jump in the boat to ask you.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa. This boat cannot handle you too, man. Just get off.
I have one more question to ask myself.
Okay.
Where was...
What was the island she was hiding at?
She?
I lowered my hood.
You're like him.
So there are three.
Good to know.
So who is she?
So one of the importants to me.
Okay. Well, did you heard about the...
You heard about the attack on... what was the island called? The other black hand part.
I don't remember his name. Caligos.
Robin Caligos.
Did you hear about him?
Yes.
Well, so...
Yes, no, the frost...
No, the frost spring.
Yeah, whatever island up.
Anyway, whatever the marine post he attacked there,
someone saw another flying...
Devilthroat user, but they also mentioned that it had white hair and red eyes.
So...
Thinking that it's probably the one that you're looking for.
Have you heard from the...
The guy, because I've heard that he got captured.
Oh, Robin Caligos self-capture.
Well, there's your answer. That's all I know.
Well, if anything more comes up in your network of whatever you're dealing with...
Okay. What will I get in your turn?
Our help if you need it.
That already have that...
Look...
I'm a business person, all right?
You have to make a deal with me for me to hold up the end of the deal.
What do you have?
Okay, how about this? You give me...
You know what?
I'll decide later.
Is the boat just dealing away what they're talking about?
No, no, it's just there. It's just there.
Yeah, but I could get you up. It's fine.
Yeah, but it doesn't matter if it even if it like goes away, it just flies over.
You know what? I let you know.
If I find anything, I'll just ask for what I need in return.
We can work with it.
No, no.
Okay, you return. As you return, you see her turn out like a couple of pages from the notebook.
As she like just tries, starts to fold the paper into like kind of like a jet like origami,
like jet attachments. As she just attaches that to the back of the boat,
the things actually turn into like jet engines to like propel her boat further.
So basically she makes like a rough origami of the thing and it actually converts into the
object. And she looks back at you guys. She goes, well, I'm off suckers.
See you next time. She'll boost away this way.
She turns around and just starts going this way.
There you go.
What?
I'd like to radio her.
Okay.
She picks up. She says, you miss me already?
I was going to say welcome to the math parade.
Interesting.
She goes, she turns it off.
No.
Well, they go.
I think that was like, what was that five hours? I don't know.
It's well for me. So for me, it's over.
We got we got sidetracked a lot, but holy shit.
What?
Didn't you need to go?
I did.
Yeah, but then you got lost too much in the sauce.
It can wait. So let's get that five going.
No, no, no, no, no, we're not doing that.
Now I'm just I'm just skipping through.
Something's going to happen.
Okay, okay, sure, sure.
Yeah, it's just one fight.
I'm going to say just for the time being, I'm going to say like a
upper hours past.
So it turns out to be like around night time.
So I can, you know, transition to nighttime.
So everyone can take up their
Yeah.
Let's see how much you've grown now.
Same to you.
You see, well, and sorry,
a absent from this meeting or this fight,
they're down below at the deck.
The usual suspects are here on the crow's nest.
And the other two guys are probably here watching.
Who's going to, I was going to referee this match.
Yeah, well, it can't be the first thing, because that's the
thing. It can't be the second to that's me.
Yeah.
So, Roma,
yeah, he's not going to show up today.
So, Roma.
Roma. Roma is missing. So let's Bob.
Bob is also dead. Yeah, I'm here. I'm here. All right.
Wait. Uh, right. Roll for initiative.
Sorry.
It's gonna be crazy if it's the same.
Not this.
Oh, barely, barely. Uh, it's mouth is first.
Okay.
So why are you here?
Don't make sure everyone's here.
We can't hear you if you're talking.
And then you might say he was stepping away. I'm not sure.
I say, I say.
Uh, do you want to continue then?
Yeah, I guess we can continue.
All right.
Malfa's.
What are you doing?
Going bird. Let me go bird for you.
There you go.
All right.
Uh,
Malfoy's is monk.
Yeah.
18 heads. I think. Yeah.
Okay.
Why is it slashing?
No, but also I come to the second one because that would be a bonus section on the
use bonus action already.
Oh, yeah, you use the bonus action. Okay.
No, Mike. You just transformed and the first hit, uh, uh,
Baptiste just blocks with one hand.
It just grabs your arm.
All right, Baptiste. What are you doing?
Oh, holy,
a knockout strike, which actually it's.
Holy shit.
Hey,
over in one round.
Oh, holy shit.
It's 16 and 12.
Oh my god. Okay.
17. No mine.
That's not some out of bird form.
Plus does two damage.
Oh my god. Jesus Christ.
28. I got there you go.
Oh my god.
The story.
Dude.
Just finish it already.
You fucking bastard.
Then you're still you're still gonna be again.
No, no, no, he is too.
Okay.
You're playing for me, but don't talk to you just then.
Oh.
Watching all these fights.
Yeah.
Like they're together before.
I think mouth is hitting him was the first time that his like,
no, for it wasn't able to like minimize the damage.
So I kind of say it a little bit.
But he's swinging.
But also, he's probably in those methods like his bed angle or something like his death zone.
He taught him so he knows all his weakness.
And that's my turn.
All right.
So mouth is you go in with your first hit.
He just grabs your hand and with the next you see like,
we punches coming at you at the same time.
One of them is you in the stomach.
The second one hits you in the.
Yeah.
One on the stomach one in the gut and then a third one right in your face.
As you go flying in as you're like,
transformation goes back and you're like days.
You have no idea what just happened.
Okay, it's your turn.
Holy shit.
If you got that lucky against well, holy shit, you would have killed him.
I'm sorry.
14 is not hit.
I don't think.
If I do to you, you just do for it.
Yeah.
Yeah, 40 probably doesn't hit.
No, no.
Looks like a gross bell.
You have nothing to lose.
Yeah.
16 hits.
My 18 is 16 so it does hit.
Yeah, but that's half damage.
Oh, holy shit.
The second one also hits.
Yeah.
You remember the game is for the talent that hit.
No, it didn't because I was a boy who's actually too hit again, but I used my boys.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, he didn't do the first hit anyway.
Yeah.
Okay, so.
Malto said this point kind of comes to and he tries to hit you twice again.
But he's seen it happen.
He hasn't felt it happen before.
As soon as he punches through you, he feels like kind of a weight as his fists touches yours.
And he sees like his fist just going through twice.
Is he doing?
All right, he's trying to regroup.
What are you doing?
I'm taste.
I mean, he's just writing.
Yeah, he has a lot of distance.
These things you run away.
He's just like, "Malphist, now, fist, now, fist."
I'll move my 40 feet.
And then,
I'll, I'll be like, "Do this."
They might do the bad arms of Astral Self.
There you go.
Okay, explain to me how this is happening.
As I walk up Malphist,
you just see four, what?
They didn't four or two right now.
It's two.
Like the boy starts to rift behind me.
As two
starry looking arms just start forming.
And as I get close to Malphist, they fully form.
And you have to make a deck saving for him.
This is the other day I shouldn't be good at.
"Malphist, guys, I'm not."
That was just a shit rolls roll.
I don't know what is happening.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, okay.
I'm out.
All right.
"Lineboard."
Well, that's all it does, eh?
Yeah.
Okay, so how do you want to finish this off, that piece?
"Mr. Hydro-like 50 damage in a turn."
Yeah.
"The crazy, I think that's the first time I've landed all three."
Yeah, that's crazy.
"And got a crit to finish it off."
That's insane, bro.
Oh my god.
Yeah, so he just basically is walking up as soon as the arms more,
it just like explodes for us in that radius around me.
And just gets knocked out by that, I guess.
All right.
You guys still have muscle ironed.
Well, that's it.
That's for the fight.
And Bob, you were the only one witnessing that
because I guess Roma was busy cooking.
Yeah, holy shit.
Jesus Christ, you...
Bro, that's crazy.
I am...
I feel so bad.
You need to, okay, whatever the fuck was that about.
Yeah, holy shit.
Dude, they tell...
Yeah, that misses, that misses.
Do it again.
Yeah, that misses.
Holy shit, bro.
That's crazy.
And that hurts.
Oh my god.
Bob, what is your opinion as to what just happened?
Bob is just silent.
Bob cannot explain anything.
I'm not saying Bob.
Well, I'm just putting on my mind is like,
dice tell the story.
type it as in game, in game bab
to draw The Six and eight and in the fight
6, 2 hits and accretes
that's still the story
Nena, main in character
in character
yeah yeah that's what I'm
uhh, yeah.
In 24 seconds, thousands is down.
Yeah.
You know, it was probably like, you know, how they drop the handkerchief and to signal the start of the fight.
So, yeah.
Drop the handkerchief from his hand, the fight started and before it dropped to the ground, it's done.
Yeah, Alicia.
Oh my god, it broke.
It was like, look at the rose, look at the rose, you're gonna be fucking insane.
Dude, what was those inches in the fight in the core?
Alright, let me recap the fight.
Bab says, Bab says go, mouth is jumps in, transformed, rise to head, that tease, that he grabs his hand and just fucking,
which is three times one of them crits, all of them knock out, it knocked him out of the hybrid transformation.
And the next strike does even more damage.
So, it knocks him down to five HP and then mouth is trying to hit him and run away.
And then the next turn, Bab says just fucking does his arm move, like arm so far.
What was it called?
Arms of as soon as they show up and that's just enough to do enough force damage to just knock Bab says mouth is off.
It was like over two rounds.
It's like, it was bad.
Oh my god, also though, it is not helping that mouth is just rolling bad all the time.
I missed everything.
Yeah, it missed four hits.
To point it out after the fight was over, mouth is rolling.
Like he got a 20 and told everything.
And then tease fill every hit after the fight.
It's crazy.
It's insane.
21 and 10 and 20.
Yeah, that's crazy.
I walked away like this fight was going to be a while.
I come back and it's over.
I'm going to get going to get popcorn or something.
He is back and there's nothing to do.
What the fuck?
You miss it.
What happened?
I was getting popped.
Would you like to find out firsthand?
I'm afraid you're ready for that.
I'm afraid you're going to get scared.
That's great.
Well, all right.
Well, for the next session,
at least we can start with like the actual story stuff.
Finally.
Yeah.
I'm afraid you're going to get scared.
I mean, I'm thinking that I'm gonna let the next island you guys stop by. I think it's probably a good idea to restock and have like, go through like a couple of merchants stuff like that. So we'll see what happens then.
Sopping up is a...
Don't worry, don't worry... I'll give you nightmares before I do the shopping session. You've been having too much fun.
No, no, no, you know, you need to have a balance. You stop to appreciate things if everything goes smoothly.
Not in my watch.
Prepare like four different possible crewmates we can have so we can choose between them.
You have a bar. We need our bar back. I need that barbecue inspiration.
Red will be probably for some of the NPCs. I'm already telling you that I convert it to NPCs and the PCs.
I'm having like a separate story from them for the side.
Red and
Sapplia both have something going on.
Sapplia I'm telling you right now. She's not conscious at this point, but Lynn is
trying to do something and also you have to get in contact with them at some point.
Lynn should still have that Dinden mushy, right? That we gave him?
No, no, no, no, no. Only two pairs of then mushy's you have. You have one for Will which is now with
its her face.
Zen.
No, because Will wouldn't because he would have known that Lynn was coming back to the island.
Fuck.
Yeah.
Is there like a whole service that goes back to the island?
Again, Veil said there's a way to contact them if he has access to the papers that is on your missing
ship. So once we get to that,
so you have you have,
Mara mushy you have Warro mushy.
No, you have Warro's and then mushy.
You still considers red and Sapplia part of the crew, right?
Will or who?
Red and Sapplia.
Red and Sapplia are still part of our crew or do they?
Yeah, I mean, red just momentarily asked to leave. Sapplia is technically still part of your crew.
You're just taking over her position as Captain Baptiste unless she comes back.
Yeah, I mean, it's a bit different, but they're out of the picture right now. So you don't know.
Yeah.
Yeah. So their stories is happening on the side.
If they get, if they succeed in their stories, which I'm going to roll for, then they might come back again.
Otherwise, you will maybe hear about it in the newspapers, but that's about it.
And this time you won't get the East Blue Harrel, you will get the World Economy Journal,
which is the journal that is spread all throughout the world,
instead of just in one place from East to East.
So you will get world news instead of like this specific sector's news.
The Roll the Economic Times.
What?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it is called World Economic Times.
Well, the journal is called Journal.
One piece.
No, it's called World Economy News.
Yeah.
I got a test Bob's metal.
Which I've proved that he likes to run away.
I got, I got a knockout somebody like, Roba, Roba's sitting good.
What was the spiders in this reaction to me and Malfa's despite?
They were not really paying a change.
They were mostly here to see the six falls, but I guess they did see
the McDonald's.
He stopped as fast as knockouts.
Oh, my God.
Well, you should.
Yeah, but yet they were pretty surprised by how it turned out.
I'd say that.
Did you see the comment?
Just wrong.
I wouldn't want to pay for those fights.
Imagine sitting at home watching the fight go to the bathroom.
I'm back and someone said the fight is already going.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
I come back and the fights are already out like what?
Yeah, I love that every time Roba speaks, all the characters are just confused.
It's just to go to his after me.
It's not funny.
What's your name?
Instead.
I will be honest the whole time I was talking to her.
I just kept calling her.
Roba, we'll do that regardless.
I was just like girl met up like.
So I forget her name.
No.
Half the time I'm trying to say veil.
I say will like.
I think at this point,
we'll just accept it that you call them.
I don't think he cares.
Bob's easy.
Yeah.
I call him fucking Zapto.
Baptiste of captain.
So you kind of respect us.
The only one who actually knew like from the beginning.
Yeah.
Um, Roma, we got to talk about your backstory a bit more because I think at this point,
the only people who have not like done much from their backstory stuff is
maybe even mapped that piece in Roma.
I think other than that, everyone is good.
Like what more do you want from Roma?
He's a traveler.
We'll talk about it.
Maybe we'll go back to the childhood parts because
uh, for the black hand part,
we're good.
I don't think we need more than that, but I need to tie you in somehow.
I was locked up for the most part.
You were up to, but I want to, I want to do more like detailing on the escape part.
None of that.
So we'll talk about that.
All right.
I know it.
Would that be his backstory?
Uh, my bad.
It's up to you.
Would you have told Malfus your backstory, like how you escaped and all that?
I'll tell you what else.
Yeah.
Okay.
I'll let you know like some of the details, but you, which
Baptist would probably tell Malfus.
But yeah, uh, yeah, we're on the small.
Mm hmm.
Yeah, what we say, Malfus?
Yeah, I would have told him as well.
Yeah.
Uh, I could have been a cook at the facility that was holding you.
No, no, not because that is has been in the black hand crew for about 10 years.
You just joined like a year ago.
Yeah.
So that would make sense.
Yeah, I know, I know, I know, I know.
It's crazy.
Would have allowed a meat to work as a cookie.
Yes.
That's crazy.
It's a, it was a world government facility.
Yeah.
Uh,
all right.
Well, I'll see you guys next week.
Uh,
did you guys play any Baldur's Gate?
Well, it's gone or no?
No.
Yeah.
All right.
Well, anytime you want to play, let me know in the, in the group.
Whatever.
How are we doing it?
10 hours session next week?
No, I cannot, man.
I cannot ride that much, honestly.
And even I can't do that because my final third.
Yeah.
How many, how many hours can you do?
I mean, I can do three and four.
That's okay, but I think more than that, I'm, I'm, I'm unable to.
Uh, that's fine.
We'll, we'll just start a normal session time and you just let me know whenever you want to, you know, stop.
Yeah.
Two sessions a week instead.
Well, what the fuck are we going to schedule that?
That's what after the others.
No, my God.
I mean, the problem is mostly like setting up maps.
Because for three hour session, I mostly know where you'll guy, you guys will go.
Like if you're on an island, you're probably going to be on that island for a while.
You want to just fucking get and get out, right?
But for like five, seven hour sessions, it's like you've done everything in the fucking
island.
Fuck you.
I can do this.
So it's just the battle maps and the tokens for the people on the island that I'm a bit worried about.
It's so detailed.
It can just be like map items.
Yeah.
I mean, I guess so, but for Zim, I kind of needed that.
I just made it up, but all right.
It's fine.
No, I just have a Pinterest opens a one piece character design and you were like, I was
using black code.
I mean, I just saw the black code.
I saw like the basic design.
I was mostly going for human sort of human.
And this seems a one piece human.
So I was like, all right, let's go with this.
Okay.
But I'll go now for real.
All right.
See you guys next week.
I'll text you about your back story about Decentrum.
I'll talk about it.
Right.
Bye.